93 double-check yeah there's no Bishop
b4 either cuz 93 double check and then
queen chief or his paint off did I miss
[Music]
what's he gonna do only blocks on g2
after Queen age 681 rook rook to you one
check rook to when she would check
Intermezzo saves the rug going this
isn't it he blundered his rook oh my
gosh he goes for a winning line and it
misses whoopsie one check that was so
brilliant rook e1 check would have been
okay Abby when she won King f8 you have
rook takes e4 and white would have been
completely winning everyone
[Music]
I believe we are live with the next
round of the speech Chess Championship
yonder pom Yoshi Alexander grishnack
Russian on Russian action proves proves
itself here to be I think one of the
most exciting matches we we're gonna
have I guess we'll see if it proves
itself Robert are you ready I'm
absolutely ready I'm pumped for this
match because on paper it's one of the
most even that we've had we just saw MV
l beat Dominguez in a very close battle
that was deciding the bullet and I think
the same might be said about this
upcoming match between Yan and Sasha
Gray shook here well yeah our our data
really is actually has a lot to go with
these guys they play a lot on our site
both in the speech Chess Championship
and and outside of it so as much as the
MBL versus lay near Dominguez Perez was
predicted to be closed this one is two
with an interesting slight slight favor
favoring to the lower seat similar to
when Levon Aronian was slightly favored
versus Fabiano Caruana
but okay we will see if that if that
holds up obviously we've had a lot of
faces already already show themselves
here in the speech Chess Championship
and let's remind everybody what we're
playing for here is the match is gonna
get set to start lots of prizes on the
line with every match they get bigger
and better the format here everybody is
going to be 90 minutes of five-minute 60
minutes of three-minute and then half an
hour bullet the great equalizer the
great decider the bracket is is as you
see it right there right we've got the
bracket ready to throw down here between
the six and the 11 seed the winner of
this match will face the winner of
Sergey Karjakin
and the Polish rising superstar young
Christoph Duda and I don't know that we
have much much more to wait for the
players seem to be ready Robert and if
we are logged in to to live chess I say
that you know sort of rhetorically I
think it's time it looks like the games
have begun yeah and we see that the
clock has just started for yan i don't
know if he knows that indeed he does
they're good I was concerned about him
for a second there because you know he's
such a quick player that's spending
about 10 seconds in your first move is
that the ordinary but yeah
that's LHS cute chest
LHS askew and yeah I don't really know
where that came from you LHS is Ike
askew I always thought I always say LHS
IQ y-you know but you know I don't read
so you have the Danny wrench school for
kids you don't read good that's right
me and Ben Stiller holdin it down so
thanks to everybody for being here we
see the chest bra in the chat we see
chest Bay thanks to all of our mods and
all of our subscribers in the twitch
chat over on chest TV we can see we can
see everybody here and appreciate it so
here we go we've got mainline theory a
little bit slightly more offbeat than
what we saw MV l and Lanie aired Omega
spreads light this is well known stuff
and what can you what can you bring the
fans here Robert well I mean right now
you see that white has jumped out with
the Queen to the a Foursquare which
pressurizes the c6 square importantly
the bishop on b6 at some point could be
attacked with a move like Knight to c4
but black at the same time is hoping
that the pressure in the center will be
enough for full compensation and when I
take compensation it's equal material
but weight has such a large spatial
advantage in the center but when you
have pawns not in the same file and in
fact this pong g4 can become a quick
target and well it looks like white is
more familiar with the opening
considering the initial time advantage
here and I just got word from our stat
boy that's my fun master Mike he said
that like sis there are lakeisha's I
don't know pronounce that is a Greek god
so I'm sorry is a yeah ancient Greek
religion that's what I've been told
right now so that's where John's handle
comes from here on chess calm okay we
learned something new every day it's
interesting that we've had in place
several matches and never really known
where where that came from but now we
know yonder pom Nia she's a username is
a Greek god and that would make sense to
sing that he's got a bit of a warrior
there I'm and I'm gonna guess that is
the henceforth Greek god but I know
chess not Greek mythology though my wife
is great so I'm
maybe I should know more who knows here
we go
alright so white wins the pawn on c6 /
b7 but black has the bishop pair seems
to be roughly equal regardless of white
well I guess I guess black is preparing
to perhaps when the pawn back right now
he can take on f3 Robert is that
possible but the Queen now protects the
pawn to e4 as well so there's Bishop
takes f3 Knight takes f3 d4 and e4 still
remain defended I think what you want to
do is black and just leave this night on
g2 for a bit because if you move the
knight from d2 I'm going to take on f3
ruining your pawn structure right if you
don't move your night well your Bishop 1
c1 has no clear path out into the open
so move like Bishop a5 also seems
attempting the point being that I'm sort
of pinning all of your knives rook b8
also makes sense yeah now B 3 and B 3
just played to get this fish about I
think Bishop a5 feels like the right
continuation because you're pinning the
meta and d2 threatening to take the
other night on f3 and the Knights are
sort of awkward with these bishops
aiming right at them and white does not
especially want them to move pawn g2 to
g4 because if you play g4 one I can
consider sacrificing at any moment on
that Square but most importantly your
King side feels a little bit iffy so I
think Bishop a5 feels like a good move
just to sort of pressurize White's
a current structure and you know I'm
trying to think of another move that
Queen and c6 is actually really annoying
it's preventing me from getting any
extra counter play with a pawn to c5 it
protects the e4 square so the Queen on
c6 is a very very good piece and yeah
it's I don't know it looks so far it
looks like everything's going yawns wait
niebo because he's up well 2 plus
minutes on the clock
and so rook East 6 was played trying to
kick that Queen off and putting d5 if
white plays d5 himself
well then Chris ship will say your pawn
to e4 is a target my bishop on d6 is a
new lease on life hitting the F 2 square
and you know it looks like we found a
clever solution for the time being to
position like you know he's the tree
- see - but then black can consider
moves like pawn to c5 just trying to
attack the center
he said pawn to c5 or pawn to d5 I
missed that well both but I was saying
pawn c5 but you could also get up on I
and Queen dick could come to you seven
or eight
well Queen e7 you might run into d5 then
with rook getting trapped but yeah you
can start pressure been more pressure on
upon a port shoutout to our first
donation of the day that goes directly
to the prize fund 600 biddies from B art
Peterson if I if I said that correctly
the art must be related to Bart Simpson
only only only well known Bart on the
planet but thank you so much reminder to
everybody that all funds raised during
the match today go directly to the prize
fund for the players so the okay so
Bishop takes f3 is played now obviously
as Robert was highlighting the knight
can't take care without the e4 pawn
falling so you're forcing G takes f 3
unless white decides I'd rather actually
give the pawn back then open up my King
which I wouldn't be surprised if he does
honestly taking with the pawn and
immediately Knight h5 followed by rook
g6 and the Queen comes out and I'd
actually be much more afraid of getting
mated than it would about giving back
the loan Pesce and after pawn of three
actually have 95 which is even more
powerful because you had a temple and
that queen with the what kind of one is
under ah yeah so it looks like it's
pretty much forced yep
but black can't I mean has to be
thrilled to be in this position all of a
sudden you've gained your pawn back yeah
you know you're not winning nothing like
that but the same you're not down any
material you're ninety four is very
essentially located in a nice little
place if anything goes to e5 yours and
the f6 move to kick that piece out yeah
so I think the main thing I look at
right now has been as is the time
advantage more than a minute on the
clock for an upon the Oishi here and I
think okay so black is clearly happy he
got the pawn back and has the knight in
the center but it's it would be hard to
say that white is really worse here
right I like this move Queen d3 perhaps
white prepares to double rooks on the C
file and if black doesn't do something
to change the structure as it is Robert
whether that be C five or so okay he
goes for C five I was gonna highlight
that if black doesn't change the
structure the truth is white is the one
potentially better here if you give like
just a few moves black would have had a
ton
weak pawns to deal with so so okay so c5
makes sense and grishnack actually keeps
the tension which I like because if the
trade happens on d4 this d5 pawn will be
isolated in the end right and that's
what it's interesting because white had
the isolated pawn a second ago it still
does technically on d4 but that's gonna
be traded off so it looks probably
thinking do I take on d4 now is there a
way I can maybe leave the tension just
for another move I don't just see a
useful way to do that I guess we go look
e to c6 and there he plays it and the
point is that you're challenging for the
C file yes you're gonna have a an
isolated pawn on d5 but if you get
control over the C file that seems like
worthy compensation for the fact that
you have this weakness on the d5 square
so it takes on c5 everything traded with
the night
I like that decision I was just taking
with the rook seemed pretty natural but
at the same time with after rook takes
d5 you could have taken on see if I put
the Queen on d4 now with the Queen on
III well you can go right look back to
e6 is certainly an option hitting that
Queen on III and Queen b6
well I don't know about that because I'm
immediately worried about 94 now yeah
and he's 94 hangs rook on but it's
coming in to f5 oh yeah then here comes
the Queen to g3 or maybe a four key mode
on e7 yep this is already looking pretty
tough for ya and with less than less
than okay almost less than 30 seconds
I'm also anticipating yeah in keene each
sevens a very good move because Knight
East six ran into Knight East 7 check
that's the problem with rooks in the
same line is there they protect each
other for the moment but you can
distract one and so by plank th7 you
avoid any 97 check ideas and you know if
I'm white I say rook season d1 slide
that rook out of harm's way on the C
file hit on five it looks very good
if the knight moves from c5 ever your
queen d3 with discovery idea yes of 1996
I can just take one b 5x and this is one
of those positions where I anticipate
Queen d3 or Queen g3 here but it's one
of the positions where you start to see
a number of things loose a weak pawn a
king on an open diagonal right a
potential g7 squared that may be the
target of tactic so you start to see
even though that sounds a little vague
but it's very anti karpova in chess to
have a whole lot
potentially lose weaknesses and and
honestly that's how tactics happen in
chess so makes you nervous for black for
sure
Pino 72 for diamond member says he hopes
the this duo plays as good as the last
duo in the chest TV chat I think we're
in for a treat today Robert absolutely I
mean we already got getting up to a good
start here and we'll see if Chris
chicken hold this pawn down endgame it
looks very tough with his lack of time
the first thing I'm noticing but yeah
he's down a full pawn and granted that
there's three on three on the Kings side
only two on one on the Queen side which
leads me to think that yes black does
have good practical chances in and over
the board classical game well not
anymore I don't know they say that
problem with rook d5 because now you're
a Python is in turn a c4 here wins the
a5 bond and that should be that should
be it because next before Nelly attacks
85 it also hits the man on c5 so here it
goes
just takes a five and okay Brooke will
fight on he's very good under the duress
of time show that's the thing about him
he gets some time trouble in classical
chess and you know plays with 30 seconds
on the clock there so he's not worried
about both night tonight at for rookie -
got it
I'm not I'm not totally sure what it is
the fans like about seeing Russian on
Russian crime here but we've got more
prize fund donated than we did in the
entire last match and we're about five
minutes in Roberts so it's fun to see
the fans showing their support and who
knows where who knows where that'll go
today but thank you everybody and now
we've got a fun one here because this
this will lead to some instructive
theory if if black can hold this
position I mean what is the theory here
you've got Knight and Bishop type of
positions where everything else is equal
and you have a rook I think the knight
is probably better at holding the draws
then the bishop is but if you're give
give the fan some advice what does
blacks defensive setup if possible here
for black to draw yeah the knight is
there goes the ambulance that's for six
chances we've had we've had for 10
minutes in somebody just lost a bet ten
minutes before Robert would hear the
first car silent and well I mean the
critical thing here is that the knight
actually is very limited in its movement
obviously right and so white pushes
forward and this is a
of f4 because by playing up for it you
tend not to want to trade pawns okay
there's only three left for each side
but by playing before you actually
trying to go f5 with check yep and push
the king backward you need it take away
the King space and look at this yeah
nice is this is really the problem right
the knight did its best to be pesky
everybody but the while the bishop is
sort of limited in its ability to to
poke and prod can only say to one color
the knight is always worried about
getting trapped against the king and
rook actually the night I think was
ganged up at King D 3 instead of playing
it f5 check and I actions already pretty
much cut I'm not exactly sure why he
didn't play King b3 if we figured he
wins anyway but indeed you're right back
in this position King D 3 the knight has
run out of options and back to B to back
to be - you can even play something like
King to d4 and now you're forcing the
knight to d1 and suddenly moves like
rook a to and as you can see on the
announce board this is kind of a common
way that the knight will run run out of
options against the Brook yep
and so Jung yon did take that one so no
problems there and we see Sasha playing
instantly this game shopkin is three
pawn and playing h4 so for those of you
who's saying well didn't white just give
away a free pawn the answer is yes but
the compensation is in the form of more
space the center pawn on d5 it's quite
annoying and hoping the use the fact
that an eventual h5 apply some pressure
on the King side I don't know sacrifice
team of its speculum to me the big
problem for black is it's very difficult
to get in a 6 b 5 + expansion the Queen
side because any time you play a 6 I can
always play a 4 and you're not playing
b5 anytime soon you're terrible Bishop
on b7 that's staring into a nice pawn
chain
what does concern me for Sasha well it
would concern me if it was anyone but
Sasha because look how much time he's
spending he gave away a pawn pretty
quickly
yep and now all the sudden he's burning
clock and the reason I don't think it
worries either of us knowing that it is
gross Shakir is because he's likely
trying to remember how he wants to play
the position rather than being Boop's
that I just blunder a pawn right
I guess we're giving him the benefit of
the doubt as you do to former world
champions and 2800 s but but I agree
it's a little it's a little unnerving
right to see him pause there after
playing so fast yep
and I just got a stat from from my
client here winning the first decisive
game has not gone well and this year's
speed chess championship only Hikaru has
taken the first lead and held it that's
fascinating so I guess that means you
know Viviano won the first game
dominguez Wei Yi at that way you was
like two and a half at a three but none
of these players could hold on to their
lead
we'll see if Yan can do sir here so
Bishop c4 queen c8 the d5 pawn now extra
well defended and that means at some
point y can consider playing to move be
45 because d5 is blow well protected and
by playing a5 I can even threaten ideas
with d6 or East and just play it Bishop
a6 I honestly thought that he b5 was an
attempt to play Knight b6 an attacking
d5 pawn here I think white spatial
advantage is just tremendous if you
played Bishop takes c4 Queen takes d4
then wipe is rook to e1 potentially puts
the other work on d1 and the space is
just tremendous so I perhaps tower
Knight to b8 it looks very weird but I
don't like my net energy 7 it's not
doing anything it hits you know the e5
square but that's already too well
defended but to really be much of a
useful idea so I think 98 potentially
trying to trade in the near future on c4
like East 66th and that way your net
gets a little bit more active Square but
I really like restricts position here I
think these positions can be very tough
to play on the black side without the
space yes you have the pawn but you're
not doing anything with that pawn yes
you father's stopped the opponent b6 is
stopped so it actually kind of looks
like an extra pawn at least in terms of
mobility yeah no it feels like White's
up a pawn if anything right but sure yan
has defended positions like this before
it's not like this is in a grünfeld or
an opening that he doesn't play but I
agree it makes you feel a little bit
better about the time that Grichuk took
after sort of falling behind because now
now he really seems to be in control in
fact how is so what if white just sits
right the rook is already guarding to b5
advance so there's not really any space
coming there immediately
what if Y plays a move like h5 gets a
little more aggressive on the Kings side
yep hey I've definitely reasonable I
think if you play h5 black make capture
because I don't see how white launches
an attack too quickly although after G
takes h5 I guess I should be worried
that a rook lifts it worked b3 and then
you know somehow that rooks swinging
across V oh thank you controlled the f5
square the night come from h4 that five
so yeah it drives everything a good move
and if I don't take it well then you can
you can play h6 but I think taking on g6
is stronger and eventually six will
undermine the defence of the g6 square
this is starting to look pretty tough
not to mention that at some point in
Aichi five will be a good move for white
so I played 95 now so 95 mm-hmm 95
Bishop takes e5 in a queen beige yeah
you can play Knight g5 yeah the Queen
slips over to h4 and ouch town on h7 so
actually the question on 95 won't be
whether he takes on e5 but does he
change his mind about the rooks and and
run away and but then you have to even
deal with tactics like e6000 fives the
mujer
yeah Gris Chuck is pouncing here leaning
up a little bit I think he's uh likely
trying to calculate these variations so
what if Knight takes e5 Bishop takes e5
doesn't change anything because at the
end of the exchange we still have mate
problems on h7 and this is a funny a
funny situation that's dangerous when
you've got both your Brooks and next to
your King sort of smothering his
potential escape turns and moves like 95
in two possibilities
yes I actually don't I don't see
anything that looks like it's about to
be crushing yeah and that's the thing
when you play h th g 6h 6 g6 you
immediately think how do i get my pieces
th 5 right that's an open file there's a
king on g8 the king on do you want of
course is well defendant that's right
you have more space and once this bishop
moves from f4 said to g3 and then Queen
h4 it's a direct path to checkmate
so if I'm black you know do I play
Bishop each six and hopefully I can take
on g5 that doesn't look like it helps
you at all because write your squares
are still terrible no but it might be
your only option at this point because
the threat of the Queen quickly coming
to the H file inmate on h7 is too much
so I guess from one perspective at
Bishop h6 at the very least it does
threaten moves like Knight takes e5
overwhelming the bishop from having to
guard both pieces here no I wouldn't be
surprised as a fissure beta 6 and you
just say like rook F to e1 just defend
that Square and defend e5 and call
blacks Bluff if you're gonna take here
maybe I'm not meeting you but now you've
got permanent problems on the dark
squares here so now I agree this looks
like the kind of the kind of game where
we expect grishnack to bounce back in
the match and of course the words of
Mike Klein foreshadowing the potential
of of the person who wins the first game
not winning the match CC I like this
move Queen b3 here comes Queen h3 I
honestly wouldn't be surprised if this
game is over in the next few seconds
this is uh this attack has gotten out of
control it also sets up Dani attactive
your queen takes d5 yes Queen h3 is just
decisive but rook takes b6 removing the
guard of the Queen on d5 while still
protecting your own queen yeah you know
that's an interesting tactic not for
this position but in general it's very
yeah now Queen Queen g3 here just go
Queen g3 at age 4 that's a you can even
play e6 right because if each six takes
you can just slide the Queen to h3
immediately because f4 isn't hanging
yeah you're in fact that looks like he
he sees exactly that a six normally this
would be dangerous everybody obviously
you're opening up the Brooke but here
the mating ideas are just too strong
east six pouncing yeah that's that's
brutal
okay so f6 okay he puts the knight on on
f7 I was wondering if there was some
sort of more aggressive Queen's slide
over but I guess you don't really want
to sacrifice the knight of any piece
Queen to g3 very nice probably now
Brooke takes f7 is forced I was born
Knight takes d5 and then Queen takes c6
okay so this is Knight takes d5 Queen
takes d5 and Queen takes c6 that would
have been I mean you just needed to get
this night away from f7 I can't let you
sit this yeah there might have been a
knight h6 check at the end of that line
but
okay g5 Bishop III then you've done it
instead of Queen a6 there as well okay I
mean you can't now to do now nineteen's
d5 Knight takes d5 rook takes d5 Queen
takes c6 I actually I mean that looks
super let's look at it on the analysis
port here fans cuz I think Roberts onto
something neither player really
appreciating the potential this tactic
it looks like that might have been a
saving grace for black especially after
the pawns on g5 because there's not even
any ninety six checks coming yeah I
agree Robert I think I think that both
players might have missed that and say
goodbye to that idea Grichuk eliminates
the knight no more yeah so he just
pushes pawn forty I thought there's a
pawn to c4 like oh can you place c3 yeah
Queen six but unfortunately with a past
deep on you're on time to do yeah it's
c3 d7 and I think that white is actually
faster so yeah okay now Knight takes c6
and the real issue here is you may find
this Knight coming to f5 and new mating
Mets on the seventh rank yep I mean
actually I'm in East 7 pretty much no
matter which well if you're Roxy said no
uncle you seven but if you go work
anywhere else at ninety seven and
they're any good a queen over there yeah
with only 20 seconds probably probably
too much to hold this one young the palm
Neha she probably taking his last bit of
time to see if he come up with any final
tricks but double threats here everyone
eise Evan okay that stops it but the
knight comes to f5 unleashing a
discovery on c7 now e7 as well as even
Knight takes g7 yeah and then rook d7
check and also ninety-seven checkmate on
the 800 give us give us a give us a
mating net were thee of tactics trainer
Queen h3 Bishop h6 and what's the next
follow up rook b7 all right Queen f5
check those we know the rooks on it yeah
Queen h5 of rook d7 h5 o rook b7 both
both wiggle in and the black king is is
toast
wow I am just like that I think we're
about to have a type match rook b7 nice
nice final try rug c7 hoping to take
with check the problem is all it is is a
check and grishnak just
walks to safety on h2 and as predicted I
think we we do have an even match
partner so there you go
1 2 1 game on game on Wayne yeah this is
already a really fun match I'm actually
greatly enjoying that and that was a
very nice demonstration by Chris show it
yells you know he had initially a bit of
a time struggle because he spent a lot
of time after sacrificing the pawn but
he's probably just gathering his
bearings figure out what exactly he
wanted to do going forward and he put a
very nice game one of the best we've
seen thus far in speed chess
championship just very straightforward
agreed maybe there was that 19:55 stuff
again I I don't know and I don't have an
engine on but that looked like it the
tactic and I just know from having many
bad positions that sometimes you just
need to believe your king right there
your Kings ng 8910 f7 you can't breathe
see I sacrificed the night taking the
garden denied on f7 would have been a
nice try and here now now we're back to
a similar opening as the last game but
the difference being there will be no
Queen and Bishop battery here taking on
c6 everyone I don't really like this
from blacks perspective I mean yeah it
feels like so what where was the
difference in this game between the
first one he moved his Knight away from
c6 very early in this yeah and yeah but
now the problem for what blacks position
is Knight c4 is really annoying because
your Bishop on b6 you didn't ever want
to take there with a seat bar so if you
move your knight say it 7 I go Knight to
c4 I'm really threatened you play
Knights HP 6 just shattering your pawn
structure and you can't move this bishop
because the b7 pawn is hanging behind it
so yeah it's he's going to d7 that makes
sense right so after 94 you a knight B
to d7 and that way you at least protect
your night with the knight but you're
not that tape with the night anyway so
1987 1956 you're probably still gonna
play C takes b6 yeah I just do not like
this pawn structure at all for black I
think yeah this opening will need some
work if they if he's gonna continue to
to take this approach I agree there's
some some improvements needed for
Grichuk
yeah this is this is not looking good
they like Bishop a7 just Queen takes b7
right and I just retrieved my queen I've
stolen when your pawns maybe that's the
way to go he just does it actually
Bishop a7 Queen takes b7 Knight B to d7
hope for a quick kind of counter play
eventually you can take on f3 to ruin
the pawn structure you bet more as a
rook to e8 or to b8 with that Cleon b7
so yeah I think it's a good practical
try because I would hate to have allowed
my opponent take on b6 where I've ticked
at the C pawn and just having doubled
pawns the B file and I see a deep on in
white we have the two bishops so a very
good practical decision microchip and E
5 whoa so if I take what the pawn on e5
then you're gonna take with me the Queen
takes b7 first ah this is a tough moment
here yeah he does go for it though let's
capture x' I wanted to play Bishop takes
f3 Queen takes a hey Bishop takes d5 but
I forgot my fish one a 7 I think so I
got in the main line yeah Bishop takes
f3 Queen takes AAA but now dual pieces
falling yeah so 97 I guess Queen takes
d5 was a bad end game so he didn't want
to take with the Queen on d5 mm-hmm and
instead he's here some Knights e5 means
instead he's down a Poland but d5 will
fall the question is are there tactics
at the end was something like Knight to
c6 so Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5 I
doesn't go for it yeah 95 was stronger
and she's now you can playing Knight
takes d5 here and importantly there's no
rip d1 with the bishop on h5 so 1985 if
you go G 4 I have Mike to be for
attacking your queen so actually I think
black is escaping barely yeah barely
there's just there's no roof d1 it's
important to note G 494 seems to get
black out of that as well
maybe you should play cheap for and just
then move your queen back so yeah
something like Queen back to f3 and
after Bishop to g6 you're actually
looking at the c6 square it makes me
wish I could play a move like a 3 and
then nice c6 forking the Queen and
Bishop yeah
it's actually very interesting so
perhaps you know what Danny maybe
instead of g4 I understand you're maybe
G no g3 yeah maybe g3 just taking a
slower approach to kind of exposing I
mean as we said it looks like black got
the pollen back but there's just there's
something really really sort of
artificial looking about all these
minors being right next to the Queen
they're like there's gonna be some sort
of tactic yeah G 4 I think is just
better because now night before Queen
moves back there's no night c2 with your
Bishop on h5 hang maybe there is right
before queen up three and night c2 Queen
of three I don't think you can play
nicely to immediately likely you're
you've ripped d1 or something like that
probably no you're you're right though
it's done okay there may be ideas like
taking h5 night a 1 and then B 4 because
if I can dislodge the knife from c5 I
can bring the other Bishop to d3 and
this night on a1 is trapped yeah that's
interesting so many hanging pieces yeah
no this is this is an absolute mess and
one of the things I think if we're
establishing patterns that might
foreshadow the rest of matchup so far as
black risk has really gotten under time
pressure much faster than the palm
Miyoshi so here he's almost two minutes
down on the clock and and that's not
something you want to repeat right yeah
especially in position like this where
they're wild text except for this is not
like some straightforward position where
users are nursing an advantage this is
very unclear I'm not even I've assumed
that white is better because blacks
position looks very fragile I mean the
c6 square where you pointed out is very
important where after night before
heading for c2 if you go Queen back to
f3 and I'm a queen yeah Queen f3 played
and now okay so Knight CC was really
annoying so what can I do because if I
move my bishop from c1 there's still
nice if d1 was played and now we're does
a queen go Oh Queen h4 Oh what now let's
look at the bishop on a7 there's some
ideas in the f2 square perhaps it's a
bishop efore now I know I you know I
need to not get my queen trapped on h4
so Bishop the e4 hits that Queen on f3
so night c2 doesn't
she hit both rooks and I see two will
just be one so so I think Bishop
afforded to dislodge the Queen from f3
it seems like them there it is
Oh Queen trade so who is happy here
you
yeah actually really likes room next to
III because night c2 to d4 was something
I was thinking about as well from blacks
point of view there it looks like the
White King so I can be a little bit whoa
oh but have $7.99 yep so this looks
it looks like he's gone yeah that the
classic Grichuk he's totally gone from
the camera
hold up Danny says they can't hear no
I'm back I'm back oh just making sure
all right so we're can this night go for
discovery check if you go night h6 just
tha doesn't do anything but I always got
a look at the double check yeah
and so that doesn't look good so maybe
night but it wasn't 85 - do I really
want to take on g6 so I just like Bishop
takes - no I can't blemish myself now
the night's action under attack so I
mean movies nights a 95 check King h8
maybe just take on g6 and take on seven
well that feels like what should I'm
more than that
hmm it's probably enough though whether
you want more or not right ah this okay
I was gonna say 94 hits up to but not
broke d8 is the moving you that's a very
good move because otherwise you'd
problems in the app - and either I was
wondering if there was 90 takes after
King takes up to night - see - but it
doesn't work white brings the bishop
back to g5 and holds that would've been
nice though the knight comes to d2 so
now Knight d3 just keep going after F -
yeah I think that black actually has
some annoying type of pressure here at
Bishop takes g6 here Knight to f3 check
and then the other night gets involved
and it's a party over here the night
good night at 4 right away actually
mission oh yeah the ship g6 Knight f4
just Forks so what you really need Danny
is a piece a rook on the D file and this
hit all the minor pieces and yeah yeah
exactly
the ultimate skewer but ok not happening
so ok so what is what's whites winning
strategy or one pawn but having the
double pawns here actually are you sort
of useful because yeah they actually
yeah go ahead they shield the black King
- and they actually keep some of the
miners out of these critical squares
yeah and they also you know there's
three pawns there but the two pawns kind
of cover the g6 pawn covers both F and H
pancit always capture Nepal was f5 or h5
the problem is drips time so even if he
has chances to hold yell they
immediately become much smaller because
he is no time with Bishop a5 nice move
this is Jay transitioning from a to
Bishop and I endgame to me now we've the
same pieces and so yeah one of those
cases where black had just so much
pressure with the Knights that in a rare
in a rare setting just trading off any
pieces is gonna make this an easier win
for white normally you may not
necessarily want to trade off everything
before creating another weakness but
this this is just now a lot easier for
white even just Keaney - okay no King
you to Knight f4 but 91 perhaps guard f2
and then prepare something like Bishop
III King e4
I like that that's great just try to
trade off his bishops because your King
can run straight to the side okay so
making one and that's they're gonna be
the innocent wait let's just say I know
it's not the same idea my idea of ninety
one with Bishop III was specifically the
guard f2 you're right so what happened
there does he have night c7 and a6 falls
perhaps yeah but I don't like this king
of seven now yeah and the fact that he
took his time after that just makes you
think that did he is it possible he just
blundered f2 I think he did because look
at his Nancy
where's it going King e6 yeah all the
sudden he's good oh my gosh
Grichuk is uh surprisingly back in this
game and he's been riding riding the
under under the ten second ride here for
quite some time
oh that Nancy's trapped so you do to go
Bishop b4 96 okay Bishop a5 95 Knight b6
gets out but there's only five check
saves the day with Knight takes b3 and
now cooking up a pawn oh hi
what an epic collapse right here by nepo
you could already see the Girish ik the
Grichuk fat head emotes coming out in
jet oh that was awesome see Knights are
so tricky yes super tricky and and
suddenly black can't lose Alex Burton 90
in the chest TV chat points out that
Grichuk grishnak loves time trouble more
than anybody I actually agree with that
and for a world blitz champion I think
it's fair to say we've seen him play
enough times in this format Robert he's
under time pressure more than anybody
for somebody who really handles the time
scramble well yeah I think they're only
several people have seen in my life who
love time trouble as much in this end
game can you win it so the night will
happen but at this point even a draws
well 97 g5 and now King comes to have 4
well actually I'm 97 g5 96 check guards
up for the neck King e4 to f3 I mean as
long as I get your Jeep on oh that's
true ok he's gonna get to h6 and try to
just hold oh yeah no need 6 ok probably
enough I think you should bring your
knight back and take on g4 Knights are
bad pieces of defending it's another
night yeah I mean that's the last chance
to try to win but I don't think it's
enough right I mean if you bring the
knight back in a three falls immediately
and even if you get you for the night
will go to h7 and sacrifice before you
have that going so and that's exactly
what's gonna happen now the knight will
take and we will have a draw so huge
result for grishnack either way though
nepo has to be not super happy there
with with how he played that endgame for
sure but the Grichuk hype is real and
and Grichuk lives
Sasha lives sounds like a better better
line so we've seen we've seen a couple
of creatures of habit here we're back to
that same grünfeld where grishnack
immediately punches d5 home everybody if
for those of you just joining us griffix
win in the match as white was in this
exact same line sacrificing the pawn
early and then getting a ton of
compensation so we'll see if nepo has
any new ideas yes so he well I need to
find some new ideas Queens on d7 this
game so that's different
so can white goat eat 5 now he 5 them
immediately keeps the bishop at c3 and
suddenly there's chances it gets uh it
gets in trouble yeah well I mean then it
was a bishop age 6 OE 5 with the idea to
play you goes for it he likes it the
problem with you 5 is Bishop e7 hits d5
and even if you try to trap the bishop
at some point I can go to d4 okay this
does not look very good that Bishop on
c3 is in certain trouble well maybe his
ideas to play
Bishop g4 then try to hit the speed five
ponts actually not so easy to keep lady
six for white yeah if you put you plate
c6 the idea is that Bishop b4 it's the
Brooklyn a and that's trapped over there
OD six maybe you'll put b7 these
positions always confuse me and I know I
mean I see an open diagonal right a 7 B
65 and I'm like okay if I get a bishop
attacking that rook its trap so Bishop
b4 doesn't make sense because then you
play Bishop d7 so that means d6 the
played Bishop before it makes more sense
and it's right but but one of the one of
the things though is that a lot of times
white is really hesitant to move the
pawns any further than this because one
of the long-term aspects of White's
compensation is that these pawns are
holding back the minor pieces along the
six rank for the rest of the game so you
really have to be careful before you
just start punching these pawns through
because black is already up a pawn and
if everything just gets traded then
there goes your compensation right so so
something like I would almost prefer
Bishop e4 Robert allowed Bishop d7 to
stop the tactic and then play something
like Queen to d3 after I've defended the
pawn on e5 maybe Bishop Bishop b4 Bishop
b7 Bishop f4 although maybe Knight to d7
comes in maybe Bishop before this Bishop
f5 for black now that I think about it
because I don't want to just sit
passively with my mission b7 so I
thought okay well he he agrees with you
that now is the time to strike and plays
d6 but but this is gonna get weird now
because yeah you win your pawn back on
e7 but f3 is falling which not only does
it open the king and double the pawns
but e 5 is gonna fall not soon after so
after rook eh I go Bishop e2 and just
protect after 3 and they threaten Queen
b8 or something like that does that work
they should be choosers also Bishop b5
there should be 5 looks great actually
Bishop b5 everybody rook takes d8 is uh
rook problems this should be five dudes
playing Bishop c6 or something but he
even
even there at Bishop c6 now we can
perhaps well I mean it's a few things a
simple move might be something like
Queenie to just a guard 'if you can even
take back on b5 with the Brooke if you
need to now he decides that there's not
enough on Bishop b5 in place but should
be - I think Bishop if I was better than
Danny your mom was better
okay well we'll find out what he's got
planned here because now I'm Bishop e2
Knight 96 do you have Queen d7 no you
don't the rook could have taken and then
defended the bishop so ooh that was his
idea 95 he's gonna punch east six
through or even play Queen to b3 Robert
doubled attack on the bishop on c3 and
f7 yeah that looks that looks
that's nasty that's the idea and that's
what kneeble miss he's shaking his head
you can see it already here comes Queen
to b3 that's it and you could tell as
soon as Knight g5 was played and we
pointed out that line that NEPA was
shaking his head that he missed it as
well yeah you really want to make a move
like Knight d4 but it just doesn't work
out you just take on f7 with check and
King h8 I guess you have Queen f6 check
King G back to G and Bishop c4 is made
it so yeah kind of counter tactic for
black but it's not working out this
looks pretty pretty over I guess is
there any conversation I played rook
taste no we're taking seventh Queen
takes c3 even if you take on e5 then you
open up the diagonal for the other
Bishop and that looks very problematic
so if you're gonna play on what do you
do you go rookie 7 Queen c3 Knight d4
but you're down a full piece so it's ya
know I think it's just just over and I
would be surprised at this point if nepo
continues to visit this line in the
groin vault I mean this has been - super
clear-cut games for Grichuk yeah I
wonder where the improvement is it looks
like well clearly he feels there is some
improvement cuz he already tried one
different variation from the first game
but I actually think you're Knight takes
d5 Queen takes e6 tactic further
analysis would have to review but I
actually think that was his
offensive resource there now I don't
think I was a good line for NEPA anyway
but I think he missed that and then the
second game so so I guess is g3 here
rights just don't get checkmated yep
doesn't mean trapped
the queen is overworked she has to go to
h6 and then the knight to e6 or then oh
I was a queen 68 check in the night at
7:00 show okay here's my better actually
well yeah in 96 they might know there's
no I was a 94 is a response with like
made under like that long diagonal there
yeah like but yeah Queen takes the 8 9
f7 check picks up the Queen back on h6
that should see 94 he's trying to say if
you take on hmmm that would be a sweet
way to end it everybody take a picture
right with your face camera there you go
Knight to d4 Oh
Bishop a 6-1 desperado for another look
at that sexy move
Grichuk muttering something to himself
in Russian that's awesome
oh wait keep it queen takes g5 yeah if I
miss Bishop g5 Knight f3 check Bishop a
g5 would have allowed knight of three
check everybody and at the end of the
line black actually wins the Queen back
whoa but it takes b7 and what's going on
so many pieces hanging on a 8 on g5 the
White has to still just be winning here
yeah you can trade Queens and take a
right I mean ok but I don't know I mean
what is much better but I'm not sure
about winning because yeah you know what
I agree Bishop a6 almost seems like it
was a little too cute to be good so what
you need to do for white is like Bishop
e3 okay Bishop Bors or if it should be
two yet you need to be able to take this
pot this I know I'm or four and then use
the open files this is not so easy
anymore I mean it's I think it should be
winning if you can okay rook VIII's nice
trying to play Brooke f3 Nepos says no
thank you
because rook f3 would've would have had
threats where both rooks are getting
involved on the the Kings side everybody
so no no thank you but no I agree
so Bishop e6 almost feels like we're
seeing the the reversal of fortune from
last game where NEPA was definitely
better and in blue an endgame and here
maybe grishnak just did the same in that
awesome middle game so how is it Chris
you're gonna win this season play f4
he's gonna play h3 g4 and he needs to
really work with his past pawn here the
the good news for for white that black
spawns can't move anywhere right the
pawn on d4 is completely stopped in his
tracks and opponent be sick to stop by
the a pawn and if you ever do play rook
b8 pawn b5 so my bad your fish of has
lost its perfect lodging on the c5
scores well protected piece there can't
be forced out so you actually really
want in a way blight to play b5 it does
free up past a pawn but it also actually
might be met by brookie five right away
up so now g5 check because you can't go
king f5 is king up three them yeah don't
beat yourself now go King King up three
kimchi for a king king of three kings
you for you want to play a5 now the rook
prepares to swing behind and Grichuk
says no that's and that's a very precise
me okay it's really important to be
patient in the technique here see now
you can just go to e2 which will force
the bishop back to c5 and there I wonder
if it's time to play King g4 on rook h1
oooh
the bishop goes to a new square but the
problem is it leaves the b6 pawn behind
yep and I think of your Bishop c5 using
over to D once just make sure that
Brooke couldn't infiltrate and now he's
going yeah the beat on this makes
perfect sense
so rook takes b6 rook takes a 4 and then
go King g4 and a 5 right just finally
yeah there yeah great point on that rook
d1 i highlighted on the analysis board
yeah because a discipline approach here
prevents counter play and now now it
looks like the two Brooks will just be
too much
rook a six and then even flipped I was
gonna say flip the Brooke to h3 and and
come down
I like trick a6 better right away I
don't think there was any reason to
force the King to g7 but okay so now he
goes with the same idea he's gonna play
rook age six and she's six Falls yep yep
and that pawn gets far but not far
enough cuz can you have seven rook h7
check
King tg6 rook takes d7 you get f5 mate
coming
oh-ho-ho-ho I saw it too and I was
trying to highlight it as fast as you
were saying it on the analysis board but
very nice now rook d6 does the same the
same idea at least as far as preventing
the steep on from becoming an issue
funny as a rookie 656 d2 you might want
to play f5 and just push those pawns but
you just go king after it EE to to stop
that D pawn and then you'll be yeah a
spawns but I think I think at that point
both both ideas are winning you can
probably rush forward with f5 f6 King f5
and g6 will be made before the a pawn
can Queen he's probably right so but
okay he goes for your line though
there's nothing to calculate with this
line yes move back the bishop has to go
to be four to hold both pawns and here
comes at five I have five - yeah I sing
broke a four I'm just you know I'm
trying to win the pawn that was just my
intent greedy greedy Robert I am being a
little greedy man Grichuk hype nepo
gives the the the lower the lower lip
sneer I call that nepo number seven
alright well there you go
and this is intense right right now
we've got everyone on the edge of their
seat because it looks like the the lower
seed has has found his groove here and
and you know Sasha got his groove back
nice reference there that was that was
very good Annina Simon it also feels
like these games are going very long
right it was only four games played and
we're what over halfway done with this
portion so yeah kind of impressive
they've had many long drawn-out games
there we had saw the night end game a
couple games ago so you know this has
been fun and okay we see Grichuk opting
for a Sicilian the knight Orff meepo is
no stranger to the night ourf from both
sides and in this variation the Queen on
g3 makes it harder to develop this
Bishop from f8 because if we play Bishop
g7 of course you're just dropping with
your 7th pawn and that's the point of
Knight h5 I mean if you put the knight
back on f6 and after Queen g3 if you
played g6
you have to worry about more of your
squares because of the Queen the bishop
goes the
long diagonal to g7 your d6 pawn is a
bit vulnerable your Bishop goes to e7
well that Bishop doesn't have the
brightest future in the world so now
I'll play Bishop e7 with the g7 pawn no
longer under attack but castling
kingside Danny it's one of those
positions are you asking for it by
castling kingside are you running right
into an attack yeah go there and hope
that everything will be okay I'd ask for
it but you know I'm weird well I don't
know if I like I don't know these kind
of structures worried me from blacks
point of view because the open C file
actually is quite annoying and do you
yeah you can't castle you really want to
castle but it just seems like you're
running immediately into an attack I
might start with f5 here for white if
you play e5 well then you won't play
Charlie d5 after 4 black so if you like
ephod do I play Queen g3 or D ha d4 is
an idea at some point he matically you
know you're trying to take away blacks
blind in the center and bring this night
back in but I don't know that right away
it's the right idea yeah I like I like
your first suggestion Queen g3 so I'm
King f8 I was wondering now you can't do
it you can't Castle queenside like one
thing to remember is this b6 pawn is
sometimes loose in some positions the
bishop might come to e3 and then the
Queen has to deal with it there's also a
5 in some positions to try to open up
avenues for the knight to go after the
light square bishop now it's a great
point cuz Danny I was trying to get in a
way to cast a long from black but
anytime you cast along that pawn on d6
he goes back to the the idea that you
liked and in grish ik it took let's see
about 50 minutes into the match before
he was completely different camera view
than what we started with I mean earlier
we were into his chin he doesn't look
very happy right now
yeah we at least he's got a shirt on so
nicely that room is white trying to take
back on d5 and then put a pony in the e6
squares oh you know how I like it but
yeah I don't even need a pony I have f6
coming if my
d5 pawn d5 Bishop b5 f6 Breyer I'm so
after Bishop f6 now was wondering if now
or in the near future 95 is coming
probably I mean that's our 96 but 96 you
I like Bishop c3 though I think your
idea of 96 as as looming on there it's
almost possible right away on a move
like Bishop takes d5 96 take c3 takes
takes c6 there's f6 okay no probably
just not enough there yeah
he has 96 now here he goes King age
number 96 he's got Queen g6 with check
now yup and then f6 falls so you
essentially you play Pawnee six Queen g6
check King Jade F takes G six and then
you can always like rook takes f6 after
to exploit the pin Zhi pawn yo what in
the world I think that's a I think
that's a world of hurt there for black
well okay if you played Bishop no you
can't take on c3 is just on takes oh
well maybe Bishop c3 pawn c3 rook h g8
but you need to defend the g7 square no
I cannot take on e6 that number just
clear because look at Chris Chuck's
camera by the way we had like his thumb
and that's what we the next image yep
okay and he's you switch back but it's
at some point he'll he'll realize that
we're staring right at his Adam's apple
so pawn takes c3 and then rook h g8 this
looks very bad for blacks this they just
tactically feels like blacks in huge
trouble because pawn takes c3 rookie a
shade even f6 okay so the Queen on c3 if
you play f6 for black you might as well
resign but it's night on e6 yeah it's
ridiculous
Queen C and work h g8 f6 is just crazy
though I mean it's just way too many
things on the Kings side yeah he takes
with the Queen no what everybody you
can't just take e6 cuz after F takes no
matter where this Queen goes the white
rook will come to f7 and it's just too
much
and too much because it talks g7 and the
87 yep yep oh he guess f6 right the line
we went for now Bishop takes d5 almost
seems like fun if you could get the
chief file going here but Knight takes
g7 is just is just Queen d3 check as
well Queen d3 check is is also on the
docket
yeah 1967 of course is gonna move
there's you're not gonna dislodge my
night with that pollen FC yep so yes I
think we're shake is busted
and you can see Poe looking to strike
back here yeah it's interesting to see
how you know they win right Nebo is
winning with a smashing victory just a
sort of tactical chest for the 96 and
made him in the Sicilian and grow shook
has been sort of playing these openings
that give more of a positional dynamic
where he sacrifice a pawn and uses more
space so very different stylistically
for both players so meal okay so now the
Queen's under attack stood to move it's
a queen c6 Queen takes c6 Bishop SIG's
an f7 and a 7 and I'm just too many
pawns f7 and e7 you you'd wish you could
force some sort of promotion on EI 12
piece back for both pawns but I don't
think that'll be possible so but is
keeping the Queens on the board any
better probably not
I expect this game to be over pretty
soon actually 7x advantage I mean I
obviously Grichuk is up a game right now
and all this does is level the score as
they say right scoreboard but this has
still been an impressive win and I and I
do feel like when at least so far today
when nepo is playing well he seems to be
a slightly more dominant I mean that the
time advantage is is is real and
grishnack just felt felt like he was
sort of floundering from the start to
finish that game and I just saw that
liquid egg product donated 25 bucks to
the the price one so that's classic
liquitex Roddick which reminds me I
could go for some liquid egg prawn
yeah we're already already at 81 dollars
in you'd like what you see fans the
players appreciate it and all five
thousand-plus of you just calm TV are
beasts JD Bryant watching both chats
here thank you everyone for being here
and for your support
yep and a little bit of backstory about
these players in a speed chess
championship both of them have beaten
Levon Aronian in previous iterations of
this event yep and Chris suga is one of
the few players with A+ score he's three
and two in the speed chess championship
historically and his only losses two of
them are to Magnus Carlsen so no shame
in that we shook has been a totally
worthy contender in fact I remember in
2016 Danny that you picked Chris Cook to
upset Carlson and win it all
I believe so I was wondering when you
were gonna bring that up but was it to
remind me of my bad prediction or the
fact that I do believe in griffix
ability to win this event seriously yeah
no I just he's a total as polar cow 89%
sasha is a beast he's going to win for
sure you know people we know and we very
much respect
Brooks chess ability and here with the
white pieces we see that Nepos switched
it up he's playing the Dutch in this
game but Lenny would be the grünfeld
wasn't working out too hot so no you
know it absolutely wasn't and here I
don't know if this is working out
particularly well for black I guess but
the 94 you are stopping this [__] run
g2 of course if you ever take on you
four you have to worry about your light
squares is white but from whites point
of view the question is how to move
forward well normally in okay so
structurally in these positions we would
like to get F 3 and E 4 if possible and
that's just a typical
how you pry open the Dutch for those
making notes of that you want to open up
these light squares that black is
committed but okay tactically f3
sometimes you have concerns on the
diagonal the b6g one diagonal right
there's pressure on d4 but I'm looking
at
I would rather still try to make F 3 and
E 4 punch through rather than part with
the light square bishop I guess your f3
I'm worried about Queen b6 know exactly
but so maybe not right away but even
there I mean I could
Flay III and it's slow and ugly as that
looks I can I can continue to try to
build up for the eventually for but no I
agree with you that would seem a little
bit too awkward for what the main thing
I'm concerned about Danny I think it's
actually a very good idea and a very
instructive idea I'm wearing my d5 pawn
because with with the pawn f3 once that
Knight comes back to f6 now the d5 pawn
is feeling a little bit loose yep and
Joseph like Queen b3 and now f3 can come
with me for and I can protect the night
and then d4 with the rook D one move but
okay so you went Knight see vow it's
gonna wonder if black wanted to play c5
himself and my plank to c5 you open up
your Bishop on g7 the downside of
playing c5 is that
well once those bishops do get traded
you you're not only for lack space and
you don't actually have the option to
start raiding pieces and what black does
want especially with his Bishop on d7 is
in no small part to trade some pots open
up some diagonals for this bishop
because right now blacks getting
squeezed it's like a this is a typical
issue with this particular line in the
Dutch this pawn being established on d5
early is not an accident right it holds
the e7 pawn back makes it backward and
white really just wants to stare down
this tension as long as possible because
the structure favors him okay now is
black in a trade Queens if he takes d5
it looks like at the end of that line
white owns the C file and that's
probably enough to be better in the
endgame but I'm not sure that that's a
transition black isn't willing to take
and he's gonna do it actually yeah I
didn't like the move Queen seed yeah I
didn't either
I would have rather have gone Queen d3
and continue to play tickle there and
sort of build up the breakthrough on the
light squares now oh there's a big
problem here Dani if you don't rip due
to c1 Bishop takes D do art and you
enter a subpar endgame but at the same
time if I'm white I know I think I'm
worse here because I don't want to take
an estate you control the C file so I
might take on a play group d c1 after
Bishop D forward to take on c8 and
eventually take on d4 and try to take on
e4 and to get to an opposite color
bishops ending because obstacle endings
are often just equal and yeah though
even if I get the worst pawn structure I
very wait but here again we see
grishnack down on time but this time for
the first time really with white rather
than black so you know what what where
did it go wrong for
I think Queen c2 I think that was you
know you pointed out immediately well I
think about trade in Queens and well the
Queen's got traded and now he's the one
who's in a worse position the large part
of that is at the pond d5 is a bit
overextended it was very good to limit
blacks pieces and that's the thing is
when you have more space you want to
keep more pieces on the board very yeah
why is because your spatial advantage
limits your opponent's mobility when
pieces are trading and as we see now all
black has the night in a bishop okay
what has more space with the pawn
structure but that's it the space is you
actually anything and this is a good
decision by we shook opposite colored
bishops he will lose his pawn on d5 you
can play b6 Bishop d7 but it and it's
essentially an acknowledgment that he
miss played the position right everybody
because if Queen to c2 was what he
wanted then he wouldn't have gotten that
endgame and Robert made a great point so
take good note of a space advantage and
how it should be played keeping the
pieces on the board and as long as they
do blacks pieces are sort of wrestling
each other for squares that they don't
have but in the game as you can see on
the analysis board black is getting
everything he wants and whites
essentially offering a draw here by
going to an obstacle Bishop anywhere
he's down the pawn and you should be
able to make the drop I think it's
should be relatively easy for her Suga
a5 all your pawns and dark squares it
can't be captured the bad news is well
how does how is black and actually make
the pass pawn because II five is the
only way to do so but I once I take on
e5 and my bishop on the beach you say
you could even meet e5 which is Bishop
b2 as well sort of steer a d4 so I go
King c4 and then I can try to play for a
5 D 5 D 4 so at some point you figure
out how to get a pawn sacrifice going
well if the King comes to c4 let's say
something like this happens Bishop d2
King c4 black might even play d5 first
and then sacrifice the e5 pawn to get
something like d4 with check if if me b2
really crew that was a very good
decision by Chris sugar things but after
intake on e4 and the reason why is now
the bishop can just stay put
yeah and out this epon once you play e5
we just trade pawns and you're not gonna
make any progress right because what the
white king will sit on the dark square
with lights
Bishop you can never kick it so Bishop
d2 e1 will be played for the rest of the
game and that and now a V 5 is played
white will just be capturing because the
e pawn can't go anywhere as long as the
White King has lodged on e3 right so
this looks like it should peter out very
quickly and that's great recognition by
Chris Chuck earlier when I was saying
trade the rooks and just take on e4 yo I
was assuming that white is worse not
assuming I was evaluating at what is
worse no I mean it was the right
evaluation that why couldn't really do
it but grishnak decided he was no longer
trying to play for an edge okay this is
this is the best chance for a win even
though still giving white a passed pawn
should be enough to come up and say for
blacks D pawn but it's the only only way
to try to make something complicated
happen right if you a d4 check Y just
goes King e for and actually you know
you do be a bit careful for both sides
in a position like that where the white
King is moving forward so yeah if after
a deep four check good to go King f2 or
King d2 then I can see where blacks
clear progress is coming forth right
deeply checking up to king d3 that's
actually looking that word that might be
winning for black because King C 2
followed by brushing the D pawn probably
enough yep so I don't expect he'll play
king of two but maybe that's what Nepos
thinking about is how can okay in fact
exactly he plays Bishop a5 with that
idea in mind likely he's preparing d4
and hoping that he can jump in with the
king but now it seems like White's just
the time to hold because yeah the King
and Bishop sort of trade places here and
likely the blockade on the dark squares
this is still gonna be intact yeah King
up to king d3 king he won and then once
the Kings no longer attacking the b4
pawn you then you move to this diagonal
the c1 h6 okay that's a little strange
but I think your draw was the simplest
buddy king of two King be three here and
even though this was dangerous before
everyone not anymore the King helps
guard this critical square with the
bishop and as long as there's no poking
here you just simply switch to the new
diagonal and then only come back to d2
when you need to guard the pawn so I
think Roberts idea was the most
straightforward but we're likely headed
for a peaceful result regardless yeah
and I think you know as soon as you go
King defy was mentioned right you just
go Bishop h6 to f8 and that's what white
wants doesn't want to keep this Patmore
passive set up but this is a draw at
this point I'm you know we shook showing
very good understanding he was lower in
the clock is his advantage which I
thought he had an opening advantage I
think for sure he did I mean we're both
a little biased toward the dubious touch
maybe but okay this is a nice way to
force the draw everyone the bishop is
overwhelmed guarding both d3 and e6 and
after takes white plays King D 3 and
simplifies and so the cha they offer the
draw extension of hands and the next
five-minute game is uh is on yep and
they've only played six games and
there's what 24 and a half minutes left
and they're tied 3-3 no I mean I don't
know if this is where exactly is nepo
going he said 36 and Grichuk said ok oh
I got a chatting in the game chat so
that when the players agree to allow the
other a 30 second break we won't hold it
against him and I also love that they
use the game chat because they're
clearly more of the more experienced two
of the more experienced players in chess
combo Denny you know I hope there's
enough water in the toilet raised no
thanks from the candidates the you know
Chris Chuck and the others have oh man
no I at least the New World Championship
venue has toilets at least if you
followed Peter dockers news and believed
that but okay seriously though we're
deadlocked at three apiece we've seen
both sides do what they do well right
you highlighted the stylistic
differences nepo when he won he wants
some really dominant games two of them
Grichuk had some nice attacks but you
know didn't necessarily finish it off as
cleanly more of a technical finish so
what are we expecting here we've got 25
minutes here of a 5 minute and and we
have we had a match tied at this point
along it this is this has been really
close I think the MVL dominguez match
was tied or and they were trading leads
a lot and that match so back this is
feels like the closest match though yeah
you know going into it this was like
what the one we're all looking forward
to the fans definitely voice that
opinion
I think in predictions as well that any
more tigress shook to win 65 years and a
bracket looks like
well I was super torn on this and my own
fantasy bracket I did take Russia but
okay I'm a little bit biased toward
uncle Sasha but he's I think he's
brother Sasha
he's brother Sasha but no and you know
as you said I mean I picked him in the
first year to make it past Carlsen okay
he failed but I think that anybody who
follows Greg knows what he's capable of
and blitz okay I saw some questions
about the price phone there that's right
all all the two thousand eighty one
dollars goes directly to players pockets
and all donations and bits today cheers
however you're into that whatever you're
into go directly to players so yeah it's
not too good comments here ibex zero
says dubious dutch simon is looking
angrily in your direction Danny I'm an
assignment always looks angry though
first of all that's the Baggies looking
in my direction it's just you know okay
Reina but go ahead and then I see kingís
gambito isn't the pressure of making a
bit of a comeback it certainly is making
a comeback
led by Fabiano Caruana little black
pieces in fact he beat Alexander Gerst
shook on the black side of a Petra in
the final round of the candidates he'd
beat the kids of its you gob in the
grantee chess classic he'd be I'm
showing everybody the opening for those
who don't know what the Petroff is it is
this symmetrical Knight f3 Knight f6
copycat opening if you're a beginner but
don't copycat it's not actually the
petrov Petroff is also notice the
russian defense and yeah how many
predictions on whether we see some
Petrov battles at the upcoming World
Championship between Carlson and Caruana
oh we absolutely will see okay you heard
it here first
well father no husband playing it not
exclusively but mainly and yes he will
try to deviate his repertory I'm sure
when you play Magnus and it's a match
but I do expect him to use it because
he's been so solid with it and I think
that's a good decision by Christian
because we talk about their styles and
nepo is a very aggressive player yellow
and he's been playing the petra does
work into Nebo style because you're
giving your opponent more space and
allows nipa to actively his pieces and
just play on the other side it is very
solid until you
forcing your opponent to come up with
ways to poke and prod to not just get an
advance you're gonna get an advantage
with the what on the white side of
Petrov but to make use of your advantage
and so here for example a leave work a
70 as the open a file let's say black
plays I don't Bishop d6 right what
what's White's next move you're opening
the exchange on the e-file for the
Brooks how does white prove that this
spatial advantage isn't just that just a
little bit of a spatial advantage so and
that's one of the advantages to the
petrov people what what is so what's the
philosophical quick summary of the
petrov black is really not taking on
usually in any positional or structural
deficiencies right it's not a game where
both sides have different positional
weaknesses and you're trying to help
maneuver the other it's typically very
symmetrical as you see here
only a slight difference in the pawn
structure and because of that if white
can't prove anything with this slight
initiative you have here the more active
queen the e-file
then you know black is black is in good
shape so you're sort of taking on a a
very healthy structure for for a slight
lack in the initiative and and hopefully
you can hold hold because of that so a
very good choice to try to equalize is
black yeah there is Bishop d6 I like
Bishop d6 to trade Brooks and take away
the e5 square from the White Knight yep
and so I he made rook d1 he realized
that we trade rooks how am I supposed to
win this game and so now we do try trade
the other work with rooks he said oh no
no go work c7
the rook a maybe is a smarter decision
its I see I'm like over c7 Lestrade
rooks and I feel under immediately you
know so let's trade on a please and
again again we see the time just slowly
favoring upon the AH Shion have we had a
match where both players were over 2900
and blitz on chess calm
these guys play regularly and then
maintain a high quality rating but I
think this might be the first one yeah
and we just I just saw a $20 donation by
the way Danny from a dogs Wow people are
loving the players and I saw actually
into the chat on the game chat by alt I
also have 780 goes oh my god Chris Chuck
is playing something
people just people love Grichuk they
really do he's a fan favorite
algorithmic Claire says Jakob got next
next next algorithmic player gets some
this is awesome but some of my favorite
hangout comments of any of these matches
the inside jokes continued Queen a - I
actually I like this though I mean we
asked how he's gonna maintain winning
chances but he's keeping as many pieces
as he can on the board
obviously you own the a file but okay
watch out for for Grichuk right now with
Knight f6 both 95 and 94 are coming and
maybe even a battery on this diagonal
hitting h2 at some point I honestly like
blacks position yeah the more I look at
it the more I I'm changing my tune that
nepo kept the pieces on the board but I
don't know that he's any better because
of it I didn't see that move coming at
all fine I take it and play 95 I mean
obviously you don't take twice fans
because well that's a problem but um but
you could take once and play 95 yeah I
think we're shakin we'll go for that
that's that's what I like ooh I didn't
see that that's a nice move
can you just oh okay gotcha take Queen
66 is under attack yeah it's not you
know oh wait I take on you you could
take a five you could also look for
ideas like Queen f5 where you start to
trade the c6 pawn for potential activity
but okay probably not enough there but
Queen a5 rook c6 you can even just take
E 5 with the Queen and everyone's
guarded right sort of that works that
looks good we now 5 Brooksie 6.85 that
looks like it so yeah and there's no pin
on rook c5 because there's Queen anyone
check in a lot of positions so so I like
that idea
what's very important to note Dany is
after this idea of Queen a5 and take e5
that white doesn't have a light square
bishop because yeah if you put a bishop
on a 2 there yep they wild whites
clearly quite a bit better with the
pressure in the f7 pawn yep having a
dark square bishop is not ideal here Wow
f4 that's a double-edged decision I mean
now you're really committing to the idea
that black c6 pawn is gonna be weaker
than your e5 fun and but f4 is a super
risky move
to both the the g2 Square and and the
potential safety of the King but I like
to moved in and I think that Khe was
very smart as well because if you want
f5 Queen b1 check would have picked up
the f5 pawn and I really like what you
said earlier the Queen at 5.65 because
this is much worse yeah I agree I think
I think Queen if I was a much more
accurate defensive maneuver for black I
think
optically it looks not good for black it
might be fine I don't know but to me
it's like well now my work on e6 is
really not an active piece is just
defending my pawn to c6 he's gonna try
to get the ladies off the board because
too many tactics on wait a second wait
does that allow check in Queenie for
Chuck followed by f5 and here we come
yeah I feel like time pressure got the
best of Grishin in this game because
this was clearly not the ideal setup to
put the Brooke on e6 rather than take
the active diverse key school and he
sort of leans back they're slightly
dejected I think he agrees that
something went awry yeah this is this is
rough and again look at the time
advantage I mean this has been this has
been an all-day affair here yeah you can
take on g6 with Chuck and maybe take the
seventh rank yep taking the seventh rank
looks great and King g7 use taken up
sticks with Chuck so here Brooke a7 the
Queen takes did you sit oh but where's
the I'm looking for the knockout cuz
black people get Queen takes e5 with
check oh good point
so where's than okay he takes th one no
checks oh my gosh take note full board
awareness all squares guarded by
critical pieces from white and that's
gonna be it indeed the grishnack resigns
quick recognition there partner
good job yeah rook on a7 bishop on d2
guarding everywhere that matters and we
have our first lead in the match for
nepal Miyoshi since he won the first
game to all 5000 of you joining us this
has really been a back and forth affair
and after winning the first game he
hasn't led and and now he's back on top
you know Jenna you give me credit for
quick recognition oh you know why I
recognized it so quickly well I guess me
PO played so quickly I'm like there's no
way Nebo doesn't see enough and so as
soon as she
six you knew he saw that that was it was
over so right and that's why I mean I'm
gonna give up kind of a trick of the
trade away but you know he had much more
time than Chris Rock I'd he could have
spent some if he's playing that quickly
you know that just over yeah or he's
blundering story or he's two seconds
from blundering yes exactly
abacus Finch points out the classic
critic face we've had a lot of classic
critic faces I think there was the
classic gift from the first year where
he was fully focused and then his eyes
just like darted to the camera and then
back and that's something I'm looking
for here okay this has to be a bad Dutch
because their night does not belong on P
six yeah the one thing about knee pose
approach so far as he's okay he survived
the last Dutch that neither one of us
like for him but he went from kind of an
ugly grünfeld which is where grish I got
both of his wins so far in the mash now
he's playing the Dutch and if critic
solves this mystery we'll see what we'll
see what Nico has up his sleep next so
what this Knight g5 thing happened so I
guess might have tricked him because I
cannot recall ever sing the Dutch word
then I belong zombie six that's just not
where you want yeah it feels like it was
a move order trick where nepo just took
this for granted the reason the knight
had to move is because it be six but
yeah that's this is an this is a bad bad
position for the night as every Russian
schoolboy knows you'd never put your
night in front of the b-pawn yeah be six
it's not never yeah I know it honestly
it's just super ugly and this is like
the opposite of that game where black
had the same space problems that we
highlighted can be a problem in the
Dutch but black had the night on e for
the night going to see five there were
all kinds of tactical shots and now now
white is just clearly better yep
chess pro oh two goes Nebo seems in the
zone and playing welcome Chris shook his
grace shook will be a close finish in my
opinion sugars good shook what uh what a
lovely way because we think therefore we
are terrific is Grichuk Danny I know I
grow up the grace sugars Bishop but the
Dutch is the Dutch and will forever be
the Dutch and this looks terrible is own
I always I love commenting on the
dubious openings when somebody's
favorite player plays it like someone
like Simon because okay you know it's
not that this opening isn't featured
even on a rare occasion at the highest
levels but often what they're trying to
do to trick their opponent was some sort
of prep is completely different than the
obvious point that structurally this
opening is bad for a reason and against
the right lines you see the kind of
situation black has here where it's only
a matter of time before the kingside
blows open the space advantage is killer
this Bishop on c8 is not playing I love
White's position and any lead diem aces
which is worse Dutch or French that's oh
man now you're asking us to I told you
yesterday don't ask me to choose between
the kids I love don't ask me to choose
between poisons you know this is tops
can I just take on g5 is you're trying
to get your something III I don't know I
like it
Nepal is a pawn so yeah at this point
black has to go for some sort of
compensation in order to justify what's
happening but I actually think this is a
good move to take c6 first and then take
because it sort of pins the Queen to b6
forever trying to guard the c6 London
ooh ooh what are you doing here I turned
on 95 and when the rook on eight no
what's he why not why are we not just
taking the g5 pawn here you can do it
now as well he should just move a go but
he's also opening the rook up to the c6
square right so no I mean tactically I
think a lot of things still favor white
but it feels like it was slightly
unnecessary at this point in your you're
almost giving black now take there why
so the Queen can't take it I guess
without discoveries like Knight to d5
and then there's a four key mode on c7
but yep and c6 pawn right I'm gonna take
on C's right but if D takes c5 even
there I mean all you're doing I think at
the end of that line is is taking g5
anyway like you should have done a few
moves ago unless okay yeah he does it I
mean this is what those things where I
admit that I am so much worse than these
players because I would never ever play
an idea like that what's probably really
really good
you give your you shatter your
opponent's pawn structure right your
skin then she insurgents are going up
with full pawn you've ruined your
opponent's position then take that pawn
tidy up the material with the long
standing pressure is more valuable than
the immediate pawn so the patient's
shown there I presume you know I just
assume that everything district does is
great yeah well I agree with you that
it's an interesting idea and I'm not
sure I I don't know that your your that
much you're really that much worse than
these players as you say I think that
when you're analyzing this you see a lot
of the big picture stuff and I still
don't know that that it was necessary
for white to do that given that he was
probably gonna be winning things on the
Queen side anyway but okay he's got
Queen c7 now if he sees it he's getting
more complicated yeah yeah I feel like
regardless of whether it was instructive
take away to see his willingness to
destroy Black's Queen side before going
for this I'm not sure he should have
black black has got a lot more activity
than he did before and then we're gonna
see one is hanging at some moment yep
so if you'd get Bishop d7 so that just
protects Tobruk on d8 and the pollen c6
and this rook on c1 is overworked right
it's under fire but also can't leave the
knight on c3 yeah this looks suspicious
so what do you do rook d1 we're seated
anyone to attack the d7 bishop no but
that looks like a draw right rook see
anyone rook c8 Queen a7 okay so he
doesn't want that yeah no I think I have
four makes sense but now I'm even
looking at shots of 93 at some point to
try to eliminate the light-square bishop
the black is like I still do the same
thing I could force the draw blast I'm
gonna keep you in my back pocket rook c8
Queen a7 rook e8 looks like it's a
forced forced draw right oh look at that
move what a strong move now that points
out that the queen is trapped and if the
Queen trades you're fixing my pawn
structure and opening up the rook the
tables have turned black is suddenly
just in the driver's seat here black is
much better here I mean the knight looks
great the bishop looks great every time
we talk about how bad an opening is it's
like the chess guys are smacking us in
the face with Karma
again I would say Brooke Abyan okay Nebo
is playing this part exceptionally well
is it could have played 'if I've yeah
but after E 5 there been night takes b6
giving up two minor pieces for the rope
but winning a bunch of pawns yo instead
he is patient he says my long-term
advantage in Maggie advantage and
there's nothing Grisha can do about it I
mean easily was work from c1 now so yeah
Brooke to be one can't go from deep one
cuz ninety-three like you were 28 before
so that was a very good decision instead
of just immediately trying to win some
material wasn't that probably backfire
he played the slow slower move okay to
be age to keep everything ended and make
progress not through that but no I mean
on the analysis board back to this
position where c5 was played again I
think that we were right originally I
think taking g5 left white with with a
super clear advantage where none of
these pieces came to life and so Grichuk
for some reason either over evaluated
blacks blacks defensive resources and
thought he needed to do something or
just frankly just missed it because this
is a game that's turning around and the
palm neo she is about to take the first
two game lead in the match we've seen
this position already looks ok I agree
this is like I mean here comes a five
the Knights coming into e3 Grichuk leans
back but not the good kind of lean back
not the R&B style 9f2 check is coming b5
can come he five can come what can't
happen here what can't happen here did
you just ask a double negative
yep oMG I'm telling your mother although
I don't know you know if anything good
is about to come out of this position I
mean whenever you say talking to my
mother I just obsessed me so I have to
move on yeah and time to move on Knight
can go to H for at least and there's
efore coming if king of six so maybe
he's getting some medical a check you
have to go for the exchange and where's
his compensation yes Knight takes up
five and no Brook out three fails to
rook do you on check so start with we're
going three okay rook up three first
but denied an a forest trapped right so
mhm
yeah isn't take taking b5 is coming at
some point oh wait a second
Bishop takes c6 they should take c6 and
he's got a little bit of compensation
for sure yeah how many pawns is he AB -
yeah mahir takes c6 I think that was
something just didn't go but it's still
I almost felt like it was dangerous no
he goes for it there was no b5 because
Knight takes e5 but now he's gonna try
to get the rook out of there so that b5
can happen if okay okay plays with g5
now King h6 I guess just h4 and he keeps
the rook on the fifth-ranked yep wow
this is actually now really not clear
two pawns for the L chain this ship will
come back to f3 in a lot of work h5
check I could see it you know some kind
of rook h5 f g5 checks having a thing
going on there and the points at B fives
always noted Knight takes e5 and yes you
can go over up to c8 but then the e6
pawn is always hanging and the bischmann
before is hanging after that so depot is
gone wrong here things how do you win
this game yep
I'm trying to figure out how I protect
the pawn on c5 so I can go be fun but if
I go rook c8 yo his move Bishop d7
shout-out to a woman's Grandmaster
alpha0 who has finally arrived everyone
so the party can now begin okay so
before afore fills to b5 okay but Bishop
before yourself pinning and now the rook
is getting overworked but Bishop f3
check yours ah
kee this should be five is met by Bishop
a3 check and do you trade the problem
with trading is then the Knights trapped
no but trade bishop be fun III maybe and
then bring your Knight to c3 just give
up one of the pawns oh is he gone for
mating attack well he's going to he's
trying to keep keep counter play alive
and this might be our first true time
scramble we've had in the match both
players really focused we've seen nepo
hold
serious time advantages but have we seen
both players under 10 seconds because we
might hear this is literally one game
where I've been able to predict like you
know you the top guesser thing right no
this is like nobody nobody has guessed a
single move by these guys for good or
for a good or for bad for better meters
no I don't think erect me don't want to
play h5 and then get yourself mated
right good 96 yeah I think you just have
to risk it he's trying to calculate
whether black hasn't made him that he's
got blessing okay we're gonna find out
and very importantly the bishop on f3
defends the h1 scores over cage for
checking g2 Bishop discovery King f1
there's no check on h1 very very
important no man Bishop d5 check is a
huge threat and look at the time
situation nepo down your bones depot
trying to make sure he doesn't let him
out of the meeting that if it's there
but running out of time to find it so
Kevin King runs why would you do a dark
square I think it's okay cuz he gets out
okay got a 3 d 3 E 4 and who's winning
now this is completely turned around and
suddenly white down the exchange has
more than one of cup a four I think
White's better okay you could play king
c2 you could even play rook b6 and Cano
rook be 64 check oh god I didn't see
that yes so he's defensive but it's the
point everyone is if he blocked oh my
gosh and he wins on time and nepo just
shake shakes himself sort of silly their
frustration coming out because that was
one that he definitely let get away on
par with that end game that he that he
got his knight trapped on b8 so Wow
Grichuk Grichuk lives and Kirk had a
little bit of a fist bump and Nipah like
jolted back yolks and he was furious
like you could tell like no he was uh it
was an existential crisis they're
finding me PO the sequel you go from
door dora the explorer references the
Finding Nemo I love it I actually have a
fun Photoshop contest lined up for the
next time Wesley so plays a for a one
year diamond membership next time he
plays the SEC but I'll keep that under
wraps okay I can't wait for it but Denny
that game was yeah that's yeah we're see
I think we got maybe like seven moves
correct the entire game I if that's
right wait but in fairness I think we
were right about the critical moment
that he should have just gone straight
forward with the kingside I mean anyways
sorry go ahead
well I just think the swings right those
kind of games where white
much better and probably almost winning
or something then all of a sudden Nemo
turns it around played really beautiful
chess
Queen b6 Queen to b6 what a nice find
right
yep Queen to b6 was really awesome and
he has moved to Brooke a to b8 after
that ever playing he 5 and trying to win
that piece so really excellent chess by
nepo there as well and then we shook in
the time screen by finding all the
correct continuations yeah where he he
found a way to keep that 9a for it and
not get a trap and then well from there
he ended up winning that game and right
now we see this diamond member Alex Alex
Burt 7 to 4 and the chess TV chat is
called it the Grichuk grishnack plays
better when he's living on the increment
at this point you know no it's true he
just that's his thing it's amazing
Walter brown I mean I've yeah except
Walter Brown would have a seizure at the
board while trying to play under time
pressure so yeah he was he would have a
fit for sure he would you know he was no
he's a glutton for time trial every kid
who grew up on the west coast Robert has
a Walter brown verbally abused me story
and I actually really love Robert Robert
would really lose I mean sorry a Walter
would really lose his temper in the
middle of time pressure yeah I like I
said never had the never had that you
never had the pleasure yeah no I mean he
was such a fantastic player but like
we're shook then you know the main point
is I just love time trouble every day me
started with 90 minutes in the clock I
moved 15 you'd have three minutes and
then it's a blitz fest and here yeah
wait so we see a Petroff again this has
gone a little bit better from whites
point of view than the last one but it's
very similar in the structure right the
only did the only differences or the
kind of the a in the C point here but
you know why I think we like way better
here he's he's really maintained the
tension on the a file this time rather
than trading too early and allowing the
simplification right so in a big reason
why that's so important you're saying it
perfectly is that if black plays d5 yep
all right so why can a black had played
b5 the c6 pump becomes so much weaker
and there's a seven pond it's a
potential target you exploit where it's
in the other line blackhead could use
the open a file bounce regain it so here
if I'm black I'm saying well I have no
space so I want to get my Queen out so
Queenie foreign
six both come to mind as well actually
am i blundering my Brooklyn eight no I
just night I don't want a combi six my
night if you take with your night you've
got split pawns and defending them for
the rest of game but I still like the
fact that white is maintained attention
and one thing I like about this match so
far is we've seen these players not just
go back to openings they played before
but really try sort of theme you know
they're they're they're trying to prove
themselves they've tried thematic ways
to improve previously right we see nepo
going back to a petrov but really taking
a different approach that I really like
here now black now black really does
have issues defending the pawns okay
yeah Queen e6 that was nice
yeah that was a nice move pin pin them
back so now you if you take on d5 866
looks really bad for him black yeah that
was the sneaky thing the bishop did
everybody ninjas bishops move backwards
he takes a five looks like the move I
actually almost missed that one of the
points of d5 was to defend the rook
Robert because it's funny right the
psychology of pieces moving backwards in
chess yep that the the bishop now is
free to protect that a1 square you have
to take on a five buddy Chris Suge is
doing well in the clock okay so he does
this okay that's also a good looking
game the Brooke off the a fog there's
now 866 Queen takes b6 and so takes but
it might just be a simplification Oh
what's a deep on the D pawn that's rough
rook the de Beaune is real I think
rookie seven only move because you need
a block as pawn some house rookie seven
rookie seven though I can take me six
and just settle on the healthy passer
right it's it looks like a block a
double passer right I mean at least for
now right but I mean time pressure and
time pressure and and things happen well
I was gonna say actually shook for once
is doing very well in the clock that's a
good news for him the bad news is he's
just down a pawn yep let's see if I
trade up the bishops right and then I
bring my king to e7 that looks like
we're very close to Josh territory but
right black has no easy way of trading
the bishops if I'm white I just
immediately dart my King into the center
a king up one can you to King's d3 you
can't actually put another attack him up
on the d5 so King f1 just
I ignore whatever is happening on the
kingside for now but okay he didn't g3
probably that's better but it looks like
black is gonna set up some kind of king
f7 pawn g6 yeah Kate on the light scores
which makes sense from uh let's get
let's get in the situation that has the
least amount of potential weaknesses
here yeah I don't know I something feels
a little bit loose about Y solutions
I agree but also you know highlighting a
long-term feature is this rook is in the
exact opposite type position where you
try to draw these engines right the rook
is stuck in front of the D pawn which
limits its mobility and that makes plans
like King c4 maybe king b5 and king c6
in fact if I get the King to see for it
I could even offer a trade of Bishops
because that might be a brook ending
that you really struggle with the rook
being so passive in front of the pawn
yeah and rook a7 also comes the mines if
you want to trade it into a bishop na
the problem is work a7 with so few ponds
it's not gonna be very easy to convert
that so I work a seven but not v5 yep
your vibes a pressure officially this
will be the last game in the five minute
portion stick around of course after a
very very small break we'll have three
minute chests and the action only gets
only gets more exciting I I think I
think this is a lot harder for black to
hold than we first realized yeah King c6
56 checks so that maybe then go back to
CPI you just kind of wiggle around go to
c5 there you're threatening both rook a
seven and Bishop c7 right now I'm just
wondering at what point well I wouldn't
look a seven nothing he chooses to trade
I think that works here because the pawn
is very safe on the dark square so if
you take on a seven fish about seven
yeah that's a great point Robert that
the bishop on a7 defends White's only
potential weaknesses here okay I think
black dose for the right thing you want
to get as many pawns as you can off so
that your bishop can always just
sacrifice itself but but will you have
enough time the g3 f3 is the point the
bish one a7 covers the g1 square
wait actually f3 g 2 you have to go pick
up g1 they're not necessarily after f3 g
- you could play d6
but d6
yeah cuz because if Bishop h2 in the end
I'm I'm sacrificing Danny out King e6
and I'm gonna put my fish 1g5 sacrifice
my bishop for the pawn wait what's your
position you're playing King e6 after d6
you have six is fine d6 I'm gonna play
King f5 your note d7 I'm gonna Bishop g5
and my King is gonna be overrun and take
your F pawn okay so I know other words
I'm getting I'm sacrificing my bishop on
the d8 square for your whenever you
Queen and my Kings and take f3 is a draw
this is definitely a draw and you know
one instructive thing that may or may
not happen in this game is that it's a
pretty easy draw when you have a center
pawn even with same color bishops cuz
there's enough squares on both sides of
the diagonal for the bishop whether it's
h4 d 8 or a 5 d 8 for the bishop to kind
of flip back and forth and always be in
position to sacrifice and there you go
they agreed to a draw and we have our
first official break of the day and just
got a subscription from Warhawk King via
twitch Prime we appreciate that Robert
deadlocked baby five minute chess is is
not enough is not enough for either one
of these guys to prove that they're
better we're gonna see if the
three-minute portion is in just a moment
everyone don't go anywhere we will be
back in about 90 seconds and there you
have it right now you can take a look at
what the predictions were versus what we
have on the on the scoreboard and
looking pretty interesting Robert these
guys were ranked just about dead even in
in the 5 minute portion dead even in the
3 minute portion and perhaps a slight
edge according to what we we maybe think
based on these guys history but at this
point this is a complete coin flip which
is exactly what the doctor ordered and
remind everybody who may may not just be
joining us this is the 2018 speed chess
championship and Robert what do you
think faster time control does that make
Grichuk play a little faster or we're
gonna start to see the fact that he's
been down on time most every game start
to come back to bite him I think he'll
be more quickly in the quicker time
patrol as mentioned he is three and two
a lifetime in the speed chess
championship he's only lost to Magnus
Carlsen twice so it's
very clear that he's been able to hold
his own against players like Levon
Aronian and many others who have come
his way but Nebo playing very quickly
his tactics have been really flaring I
mean very good tactical vision by Nikko
thus far even in some tough positions
and he did eventually lose that Dutch
game for example but he was playing
perfectly for a series of moves and his
game would on the white side that night
or if he just absolutely obliterated
Grisha so I think as much as we would
like to say he didn't lose that Dutch
game because of the Dutch much to our
sugar it was not well yeah it should
have been a loss to the Dutch and then
it was better for him and then it wasn't
and we can just blame everything on the
Dutch but no cookies they both playing
very well I think we shook sort of style
is well suited against meepo but I also
think vice versa and meepo sells well
suited against / shook because they're
really going back and forth here it's
four and a half four and a half and yeah
it's a very fair result to see a tie
this far in the match absolutely and the
timer begins as our players sit down
three-minute chess is underway Grichuk
getting himself settled before he makes
his move and again if you're just
joining us everybody shout out to all
those who've been with us all 5000 of
you thank you lamp man we're glad you're
like in the commentary can also say that
we've had three ties and three lead
changes in this match so to all 5500 of
you time to time to cancel the rest of
your plans for the day and stick around
because this is this has been it's as
many lead changes as we've seen in any
match so far in the 2018 speech as
championship so Robert here we go
well I said that I had a look at the
chess again and see a Dutch because and
we see that me both fixed it because
last time he went 97 before moving his
rook to e8 and that then Knight g5
happens the nepo course not gonna fall
for that same opening mishap again and
plays this line that's very popular in
the Dutch why it's popular but yeah
Knight g5 and black doesn't worry about
giving up the bishop when you say so
white can take this pitch 26 rook takes
dissolve and played many many times y
can play ideas the Queen c2 playing for
efore this is blacks plan I play Knight
c5 stopping pawn before
and so what white is relying on is the
long-term advantage of having the two
bishops black on the other hand it says
I can put my men before her now or at
any moment and once with my nanny for
your bishop on G - doesn't look so great
does it and here we see some trades
mm-hmm
next night can come to me for if it
wants but instead offer the Queen trade
and from whites perspective I don't
really want to give a Queen trade right
now I can play b4 and offer that Queen
trade but what's happening is at if the
Queen's get traded blacks on put this
man efore the only way to really kick
that night out is to play play f3 but
once you play up through your Bishop on
g2 is not a very good piece so Queen c3
Brooke c3 I think is definitely what
should happen here in this played and
now maybe go after the D pawn rook d3 or
rook a3 they work at a three and by
putting the rook on a three you keep the
rook honest to the pawn on a mace
neither move so shows what I know but
what's the rook doing on c2 why is that
Oh sabi Knight d2 got it don't have to
worry about that but now so clone a for
King d7 so you don't want to rush a 5-4
black because you know there's no reason
to quickly with the if you did that
earlier why could take on any form play
pawn takes a five yeah but now you don't
have a chance to do it anymore it is
this is this a move he wanted to induce
um yeah I think that black is cramped
that's the thing is and Ione for as you
know I've mentioned all game it does
well to block up this big 52 but it
can't move you need to keep it there so
do you get a snow a 6 B 6 May 2nd a 6b
6b takes c6 you can't take me on c6 as
f3 followed by F for that would be that
would be nice
tricky little tricky little Robert but
after a 6b 6b takes c6 if I just leave
the pawn there so yeah I mean even moves
like rook to c5 are probably just fine
because hard to imagine black being
worsen in a game like this with that
knight on e4 yeah you know I see the
long diagonal I just wish my bishop were
free but I don't love the mover key 5 it
just seems like it's asking for trouble
yeah
so Brooke b2 so you have to go
protect your b7 Square Knight c5 then a
six looks pretty powerful so you can't
move the knight I like the way griffix
played it though for as much as it's
been a disappointing effort for white
against the Dutch again the fact that
this tension hasn't broken yet and now
there really may be a chance for the
rooks to do something because because if
c5 am I playing b6 check and then taking
with the rook I think so hitting b7 yeah
you definitely are right so were you go
for a six again because you still can't
play b6 on f3 and f4 haha but yeah I
mean either way that looks promising
okay now there's f3 enough for possibly
here oh I didn't like that move yeah
there was no reason to take and open up
the rook and the reason why I thought
you could switch the rooks of the a file
after with a pawn a 509 b6 yeah make
them like rook 2 a1 or work to a to R
okay to allows Knight c3 but yeah rook a
1 yeah so play like guy just open up the
a file and take over the a file and now
that's a good move rook at a6 you
protect the b6 pawn now you can play
King you can't buy King takes c6 quite
yet
woo c5 it opens up the threat of bishop
f1 forcing the rook from a six so Bishop
f1 here comes Luke takes b6 1902 is on
the docket though at some point you know
so that was sneaky looking but
unfortunately yeah this is just a fancy
trade and probably this game Peters out
to a draw in fact these guys are
countrymen and they decide let's fight
in let's fight another day
that was that was awesome I mean c5
caught me so off guard wasn't even on my
radar and well it just it happened in
that case it's the lead to direct me to
a draw but very nice vision by Griffith
even see that as an option you know
shout-out to Anna Rudolph showing up in
the twitch chat we love you Anna given
the given the show sometime here you're
streaming tonight after the SCC that's
what I'm talking about let's go let's go
all night twitch party for chess
and so we just saw another Dutch and now
we see another one of these Spanish anti
Berlin positions and okay this has gone
better for black men in previous
iterations because you haven't gone a
six which actually weakened the
protection of your Bishop on v6 so a six
seemed unnecessary and in fact it wasn't
playing this one and wait a second isn't
d5 hanging no no what am I talking bill
the e1 he once protected I was like wait
isn't there just rook hanging on anyone
ignore me hey you know what yeah I know
you did that on purpose just to make
making me feel like I'm not the only one
who blunders and I love you for it no
Robert I'm trying to give you a
compliment that this show survived under
the thought that you are a perfect chess
God and I'm and I'm just here for you no
I mean it's funny and I just sometimes
just miss the obvious yet we all do that
peace is protected so don't do it
yep wait actually no I look at it again
that might have been good yeah I was
just about to say like we're just
sitting here joking so if Knight takes
d5 pawn takes rook takes II one Knight
takes a one Queen to f6 Forks the rook
on a1 and the pawn on f2 I would love to
say it's the whole time you were ever
sit here making this joke I was also
thinking about it in my head that's what
chess players do right and then I
actually I'm pretty sure this would have
just been completely winning for black
that's hilarious
I stumbled into it by yeah by blundering
and it's it led to led to fun and then
here comes Knight takes d5 anyway it's
so I love that you and I were both doing
that because that's such a chess player
thing to do we're having a conversation
while sort of doing the variations in
our head and we both realize that it was
just it was winning for black look at
you Robert accidentally brilliant you're
brilliant even when it's an accident oh
thank you that's so sweet
that was a complete I mean I'm just
sitting here like wow I'm I'm calling
myself stupid and then all of a sudden
I'm like wait a second no I know I was
looking at it too and I was like wait a
second so and by the way I when I did on
the analysis for the evaluation agreed
you were right it was winning for black
Wow so it's hilarious
but now this is also isn't about
yourself upon yeah he stole the pollen
like a thief in the night and this is
the first time we've seen Grichuk
get-get get an advantage with black uh
to my recollection in the match I mean
this is a clock yeah and on the clock so
this has been quite the the opposite
94 just winning here right 94 or you
could almost take up to first the why
allow it yeah no 94 fork the Queen and
the f2 pawn and Grichuk agrees so
something went wrong here for nepo and
as we see there right as we get in a
subscription from unlimited rice pudding
which I love rice pudding me too man
rice pudding is so freakin good that is
one of those underrated sweet treats
around us but Nepos shaking his head and
yeah back to the drawing board is this
one right finding me PO continues
finding me PO the story of better white
openings next time yeah I love that
finding me Bo so what's going on here
Knight takes e5 Knight wait 90s up the
exchange right
okay I'm blundering everything's going
can just take this pot knight on e5
isn't it a free night so you this time I
think you actually are blundering though
not not brilliant by accident no that
was just the blunder yeah Queen six that
square has been good all game funny
stuff 33 so Knight c4 is the only you
can make a knight discovery in your
protector Bishop on v2 yo night c4 is
not really intimidating because there's
between g6 but now good like you could
play a move like Bishop g6 here or
something right just to just to say
simple chess
no tactics on g7 for you yeah
it's efficient g6 is fun well I was to
say if there's no good night discovery
yeah rook d800 makes yeah at night
nicely for is yeah you can just use the
g6 square for the Queen and should be
when this should be pretty strong so 94
here Queen takes up to check would be
good so you have to take on date first
if we're gonna do something like that
now but it seems like the the tricks are
are running out Rupp D to do it rotates
you yeah that looks pretty
straightforward take on a rookie to
threatening beats youth or anything
Evans I still won't go back
this bishop g6 just because I have this
tendency to always want to protect the
g-spot but you know that's just me now
verse singe
verse in torrox for said that rice
pudding has always lived in tapioca
shadow Robert and I say no more I agree
with you Danny Grisha twins first times
have agreed with you and we just
squeezed a whole lot of a whole lot of
references into that last game and we
are we are having a good time here
another Dutch this this could be a
problem because if white gets this one
here based on how we've predicted place
should go against this opening then that
would be our first two game lead in the
match for Grichuk yep and so here we
have this again I don't think niebo was
unhappy with the position he got last
time with the Dutch I actually thought
he played it very well it was standard
yeah but I do think that Chris shirt
will change it up this game because of
course he didn't get we lost place
before early this time and the good
thing I'm playing before like this is
you don't allow night F to e4 you only
allow night C d-four and there's a vital
difference that the bishops don't get
traded right away so here Queen c2 can
be played you could kind of gain a tempo
in a sense where you know so in order
for black to accomplish this Bishop
trade you to first go Knight takes c3
and then bring your other Knight to e4
yeah we're just picking the next remove
so we're getting close to a type of
position that was just like the last
thing and we saw right yeah and if I'm
white here I might even consider playing
a knight II - saying Knights are
stepping on each other stand there it
goes and well night of four is a huge
threat to win the G and you know what
that is that's a human though this
doesn't seem like a position where if
White has more space this reminds me of
the instructive point you made earlier
which is that with a space advantage
here which white does have with the two
bishops and the potential of this
position being open you really want to
keep the pieces on the board don't help
your opponent clarify where they need
their pieces ninety two is such a strong
move from that perspective reminds black
that he does have to figure out the
Knights the d6 pawn is weak and the F
Foursquare is screaming for the white
knight especially now that g6 is weak so
sorry I took over there but I really
want to highlight that you're
instructive point about keeping pieces
on the board
when you have more squares for your
pieces that's exactly how to play chess
right you don't want to trade when your
opponent is struggling to find clarity
in terms of where to maneuver no it's a
hundred percent you mean you took the
words right out of my mouth so I yeah
that's exactly the point
and it's knight on f6 where's that going
you're not going Knight g4 what is that
that's a sort of a ridiculous move that
maybe actually can do it to hit the f2
pond yep so now that I said maybe it's
not so ridiculous now Knight g4 actually
has a clear purpose in fact Knight g4
looks really good here yeah I think yes
where did he go wrong there I didn't
love b5 yeah it almost felt like once
you establish the pressure I mean I
almost would have liked to played h4 and
Knight f4 and really the thing that's
been calling our name has just moved the
Queen to d3 and quickly double rooks on
the D file this d6 pawn is the only real
positional weakness on the board that
that's that you can target so but he
hasn't ever gotten any more pressure on
d6 and and now black may be quickly
switching to the H file right so Bishop
referee is a good movement yep yes
because you need to get rid of this
knife from g4 his Queen h6 to h2 was
just a mating direct mating threat so
now Knight e to f6 so king g2 can be
played and now we can bring your whoop
to h1 and now I think white is totally
okay again for a couple of moves it look
very shaky there oh wait look takes e3
rook takes c3 for key mode in fact
there's nothing wrong with it because
now unlike the Knights stepping on each
other's toes now the fact that they back
each other up is key to making the
tactic work there may be something with
Queen takes d6 at the end of the line
though it could get real messy nope
no he just immediately plays Knight f4
something tells me they'll Robert like
this could quickly backfire for black
because now that the now that black
stole this pawn if the position keeps
for coming open who's King is really in
more danger black or White's right
actually the H file is totally under
White's control yeah because the only
piece ignore that for black is a queen
both me met immediately by rook age once
yeah no I knew pose taking his time now
and this is back to what we've seen most
a match with grish ik being the first
one under time pressure but a sixth very
play there
possible that the black king gets in
more trouble now but as the position
opens up okay he did that I really liked
him of a six just to undermine the pawn
chain but this also looks pretty good
ninety-five where does the knight go eat
okay go to e6 yeah I can go to u6 Kent
in my piece and tell where does the
black Queen go mean g6 okay so what
black is no look at that move work CDE
one how calm yep saying that you know
I'm just gonna protect my knight your
Knights are stepping on each other's
toes once more if you I'm you're
threatening Bishop takes c6 I didn't
even think about that I was like trying
to figure out my threat was and then see
if I was a nice prophylactic move to
protect the Queen against any any pins
there and also permanently make sure
this pawn will remain on c6 that way
even if I don't take it now it's a
weakness forevermore with the
LightSquared Bishop and that Bishop
might come to d1 to be oh look at you
Robert I thought I told you tricks were
for kids yeah I've been eating Captain
Crunch but maybe I'll have to eat some
more tricks yeah but your mom okay with
that diet Captain Crunch for lunch okay
I lodged more of like a late breakfast
and I'm snacking
so g4 look at that just closing down the
kingside saying that all the positional
aspects favor white pawn to c6 is weak
Queen on d4 is exceptionally strong yep
rook e1 can come at any moment and
saying your Knights are gonna be stuck
there defending your king bishop d1 to
me am bishop did that diagon me Queen to
c4 is better this because you don't
allow any 95 moves I don't really want
to keep the bishop poking at c6 which
really keeps all of blacks rooks tied
down so I also like Queen c4
yep and me bow down to 40 seconds Chris
yerga 34 rookie 7 alright so he's he's
trying to prepare to bring the rook off
of c8 with tempo everyone so that yes
you may win the c6 pawn but maybe I get
two pieces for the rook or something so
trying to create ooh Knight f4 wins the
exchange but 90
for blitzing out moves can you can you
play no Queen f4 there's 93 double-check
yeah there's no Bishop efore either
because 93 double check and then queen
g4 is mate miss King gauge one what's he
gonna do oh he blocks on g2 after Queen
h6 King g1 look to uncheck rook you
won't you uncheck Intermezzo saves the
rug no he misses it he plundered his
rook oh my gosh he goes for a winning
line and then mrs. Rooke g1 check that
was so brilliant
rook e1 check would have been okay after
Brooke g1 King f8 you have rook takes e4
and white would have been completely
winning everyone oh my gosh Rich Jerk
missed that move a six by black hair he
was played Bishop e6 a take on a7 and
take on f7 okay it's still so King f6
Bishop f7 rook f7 rook d6 check I take
enough one okay somehow this Knight is
trapped anyway don't look at the
position yet take here and he's gonna
take on detune isn't white better than
the second white is with the only one
who can win this reckoning even after
all the blunders this is ridiculous yeah
brookey oh man no black we we have to
make a note that we have to point out
rook she won in this crazy crazy
3-minute game - Sasha afterward just to
see his reaction well I thought he was
doing that because I was like wait King
it queenie ford like i don't know we
were giving him the brilliant credit he
normally deserves but he just he missed
it that was unbelievable that game was
and this whole match has been sewed like
back and forth it feels like and I don't
even realise because sugar still up a
game because that's just how this
matches felt I guess with the exception
that game that Chris tripped just one
with black yeah they're an ephod sort of
blundered the house it's been just
really back and forth and that was the
first really one-sided no actually just
not sure the nepo win within the night
oh yeah now but no you're right that was
a game the grishnack was in control from
start to finish and i guess too many
moves under time pressure he didn't have
enough time to find the last one he
needed which was rook to g1 check shout
out to everyone having a lot of fun in
the chat using the emos red thunder
heart beating the the drum and the chest
TV chat we still don't know who that guy
is but he likes himself some chess
websites
and and yeah we've got we've got quite
an exciting match here over a hundred
dollars have already been donated by all
of you the fans remember everything
given today in terms of bits shears and
donations goes directly to the players
pockets so thank you for all your
support thanks for being here wow I'm
still just that was bananas I was I I
literally I wasn't on camera but I I
almost jumped out of the chair when I
saw Roachy one and then it didn't happen
disappointed Wow just unreal opportunity
missed there and you know I think it
reminds me of that Nakamura game against
- oh yeah yeah the the promotion yeah
when he was shaking his head for the
next like 30 seconds and hilariously you
can see the differences you could see
yeah you saw the moment on his face when
he realized it in the next game and I
don't know that Grichuk has realized yet
that he missed that he missed this win
so I like restricts position this game
though I mean it's not better but I
think he's totally fine yeah agreed
so when is he gonna go d5 that's the
question ones black and a play for deep
I maybe never
d5 obviously has the downside of
loosening the e5 pawn the protection
there so what is whites threat is there
a white thrush I go rook f7 okay does
this sit in tight this is about as
boring a game as we've seen these guys
playing right sometime well I'm trying
to figure out who's gonna play d5 or d4
first I like Knight g4 right you're
trying to force open if black took on g4
everybody he would regret it because of
g5 and the H files so why trying to
build up some tension over here on the
kingside to maybe get an outside chance
at an attack there's also night h4
coming with with other weak squares
right on g6 yep so so maybe as I say
it's boring maybe there's some chance
for fireworks well I was wondering why
black didn't play Brooke f7 and rook to
f8 but maybe there was an IH for stuff
like to mention ah no that's a nice idea
right but yeah maybe it was night h4 and
then he wants to make sure he can
actually guard this light score diagonal
with the Queen so the real kind of 7 is
not ideal oh you know I love goose rook
c8 move now because because he can move
his knight
yeah and that means e5 possible here
comes Knight takes it wasn't there rook
takes f3 first instead of Knight takes I
mean I don't know if it matters right
takes f3 rook takes Knight takes
probably still just a fancy trade but
yeah but but why I like that trade is
because you have one fewer rook on the
board yeah and I think having because of
White has more space and f45 things
happen I think having that trade of
rooks might have been a little bit
better for black I could be wrong no I
agree I went through the line at the end
I think black keep and puts the Queen on
e5 with the white queen on F free and
and hits b2 so I think that was better
for black I agree
so here how does white so ii 5 of course
10 things takes rook takes and i think
this game is living up to the boring
prophecy foretold but don't don't be
surprised if whites king gets in trouble
if like if i can find a way to keep the
pieces on the board and access any of
these open files right now controlled by
white yeah interesting decision to not
trade the queen i thought he's gonna
take on f7 play h4 and then play h5 and
king f3 to e4 because white has more
space in the endgame and it reminds me
of the ending of MV oh and Dominguez
word and there was black in that game
and yeah he's playing a great end game
with more space and so I thought that's
what he was gonna do and now he's doing
it but it's a non end game it's actually
there's a when the Queen on the board is
harder to make this work because any
time you go h5 that pawn can become a
target and White's King is not exactly
the most safe Kings like c5 here fall by
Queen d7 check okay so even Queen d7
that looks pretty good
Wow just Queen d2 I mean there's there's
no way to do King h3 and then if you if
you check back am I gonna play f5 wise
no Queen B 1 I just go Queen h1 check
Queen D check make a draw that way maybe
now the ladies come off although h5 is
interesting because here if you trade
Queens your rook is forever stuck to the
back rank that's true
so h5 may be bent another Queen d2 Queen
d1 okay so he doesn't go forward you
Queen d2 check in Queen d1 coming anyway
although here the Queen does go
the age spot perhaps p3 is now under
okay yeah perhaps we get the Queen
ending rather than the brook ending
we've been predicting and these guys
have taken the several draws in these
types of positions where they know best
play would lead to it not necessarily
trying to flag each other and just
looking for the next best game so I
wonder if we'll see the same thing here
some questions in the chat yes the title
Tuesday will be taking place right after
this event today so the strongest
monthly event on the chess web chess
coms title Tuesday will be happening
with Grand Master arm on Hambleton
hosting commentary so we won't even stop
the stream it'll go right from me and
Robert here to title Tuesday commentary
so so that's your Tuesday first Tuesday
of the month big Tuesday yeah no I mean
I depending on how exhausted I feel
after this match but yeah you might just
throw down I might I might know you
always play better after watching
Grichuk so as long as I'm not playing
him because that's a tough matchup for
anybody but yeah I mean Chris shook is
awesome so we're shook thinking I'll
move nine the option but okay we're back
to the grünfeld
notice that nepo going away from the
dutch for the first time in three games
gonna be a different variation of the
grunt field then he started the match
myth but for those of you just joining
us two of griffix win coming the two of
griffix wins excuse me coming on the
white side of the grünfeld so
theoretical consistency by both of these
players today kind of poking and
prodding and I'll be excited to see if
that makes a difference in the bullet
Robert where we've seen in matches
people go back to an opening that maybe
they liked when there's less time on the
clock for their opponent and that can be
a huge practical advantage well what is
this green fella with 97 like this 97 c5
Queen a5 stuff I mean you know I don't
know I mean it's it's consistently a
pawn sacrifice for white whether it be a
2 or C 3 and then this idea that the
center keeps blacks pieces at bay and
here comes the attack
I think blacks Bush is absolutely
atrocious right now and Knight g5
instead of h4 was one idea to go to e4
but h4 h5 9 g5 White's play speaks for
its h5 immediate I mean this is like
you know when I look at games when I try
to look at openings I think alright you
know if I'm black I got some counterplay
in the center
yeah like is done is on Queen a5 takes a
to Queen a5 Queen c7 now if you look at
the position do you even look at the a
pawn do I see I wouldn't even notice
that black is up a pawn if I first saw
this position Bishop takes g6 here the
Knight takes c6 just man I just win on
the spot I think White's just crushing
here and again I think that Nebo despite
having survived a few times in these
openings has his work cut out for him I
mean here you see a piece sacrifice and
for what the Queen comes to h3 and
you're not even you can't even skewer
the D file pieces because I have Brooke
III yes very bad good now Bishop takes
g6 is again a threat with Queen age
seven Knight 66 coming Oh takes t3 more
desperation but now he's down a rook how
many pieces can you sack to avoid the
h-file mate is the question you grease
tricks like totally off camera two I
mean these are the type of positions
that I seen from like from my childhood
where I look you know I was shown games
from like Zurich 1953 and it's like oh
here's what happens when once I gets
greedy and the other side gets a free
yeah it's like it's like you almost feel
like it's such a one-sided affair word
you're like the - Shawn grandmasters
really play that game because this has
just been all grishnack from start to
finish just to have the instruction yep
and Andy Lee DMA said Danny say it's
nasty it is nasty it's a nasty attack
that's been going wild since I said that
the title Tuesdays are the strongest
overall tournament online every month
they are the strongest Magnus Carlsen
has been rarely playing in some of the
great events on Leach s lead chefs
events are awesome as well and Magnus
Magnusson played both though both title
Tuesday's and only chess so anyway stick
around because what matters is
regardless of which top GM's played the
strongest overall tournament undeniably
will be taking place right after this
event so oh really I thought the
strongest tournament was one we're
commenting on right now because the
speed chess chamber this is the this is
the strongest overall average rating I
meant the strongest open tournament to
tell players every month yeah I agree
I agree and wait this is this is a rook
and we're looking we're like baseball
commentators looking for things to talk
about when one team is up by eight runs
you mean like when the Mets were down to
the Nationals like 25 to 1 the other day
and they're still having to commentate
yeah yep so I just took a little nibble
of Cap'n Crunch
trying to figure out what to say here
hey get your protein in ha ha so what is
relaxed idea somehow trade the bishop's
is play rugby to trade the bishops play
rook d2 are we are we still evaluating
black getting counter play down a rook
I'm not sure what nepos doing Queen a5g4
would be a nice way that in this game
though we know 5g for that would be a
fun way to hit the clock yeah
speaking of the clock 30 minutes left
here in the three minute portion so
still uh so plenty of time for a neat
bodemer versus fortunes but we're about
to see the first two game lead of the
match for Grichuk and nepo on a bit of a
tilt right now finding nepo time to fix
your black openings the fourth movie in
the series rook d1 nice he was going to
trap the Queen and play c4 in the rook
da check that was good whoa looking good
I was like why you stack crushing
through though I mean two games up right
now and this is this is uh this is
impressive and Grichuk is zoned in
stoned face and not going anywhere but
up right now so
Nepos got to stop the bleeding well I
don't know how he's going to do that so
here he goes with this Kings Indian and
he goes to the h3 g4 line I tend to like
that especially in blitz it's much more
comfortable to have more space and
glutes and have your opponent suffer I
love how you just said that it's much
more comfortable to have more space and
blitz and let your opponent suffer I
mean I'm not trying to play a Captain
Obvious reference but you're right
it is you know I mean I actually think
it's very different than a classical
game where yeah you get frustrated right
you have more space yep like how do I
get this land a knockout blow it okay
from from a instructive for
spective for the fam mean a lot of times
blacks approaching these positions is
yes you are defending for some time in
white has the pressure I think we'll see
Queen c2 here because III might be
coming to undermine the night
but even if White has the pressure the
point everyone is that overtime you're
hoping that these pawns are overextended
and so maybe there's weaknesses on the
Kings side right you hope that you get
access points to things like the d4
square maybe the e4 pawn becomes weak
which is why white plays a3 so you know
you're playing sort of a that the
spatial gambit as they say when you have
this type of position but you're right I
agree I prefer white here for sure but
you answered your own point because
Queen c2 was met by the g4 pawn hanging
so that's why you played f3 yep so
somehow we got another $25 donation to
the players and the price one here I
missed it sorry for not thanking you but
there you go the price one continues to
grows for these two crushing Russians so
8/3 Queen c2 just take on b2 Jenny your
idea is coming to life here yeah III was
that's what you expect here for black
and now h5 so again like this is kind of
how these positions sort of go right
black has less space and you're gonna
wiggle for a while now maybe you want to
try for f6 at some point or even f5 but
this is not how white I mean what you
just not allow 80386 b2 right now yeah
no you're right you're right so I don't
like what what nepo is done and he might
be one of he's gonna start going on tilt
so when I just saw someone mentioned in
the chat that Nico has a history of
going on a bit of tilt and he's only
down two games so it's not like that big
of a deal especially doing bullet is a
toss up and Nebo is you know quite a
quick player but right now his position
is look at that move forget for
positional chess yes I love that that is
such a brilliant move in and this could
be our first real potential tilt of the
match or I get your tilt emotes ready
because if you see a three-game lead
that is not what we would have expected
at this point but that is that as
Braunstein written all over everyone
it's a great reminder a Petrosian
exchange sacrifice that what matters in
chess is truly squares and the
initiative and that's what black gets by
blocking off this bishop even if white
doesn't take it black gets access to the
dark squares and access to the king
and to see on the analysis board what
would have happened you're totally
willing for something like this when g5
is gonna fall the bishop is open the e5
square is calling your name seriously
that is some instructive stuff and books
are nice you remember you just call me
Saint Captain Obvious books you're nice
goes tough to play against Kris Chuck
when he plays like this you know it's
nobody he's playing super well but I
think I think yawn has some openings to
fix here I feel like he's you know we've
we've been critical to black openings
despite really mixed results but here as
white he didn't get the best out of an
opening with a big space advantage like
Robert was saying and but Brooke at four
that's that's an instructive moment to
put in your pocket and reminds me of a
game from Zurich International 1953 this
sort of famous exchange sacrifice very
similar on the dark squares by Bronstein
in in King's Indian were white castles
long actually just to open up the dark
square bishop you remember the game I'm
talking about who I think it was coat
off Braunstein do you also show that
game at that chess camp that you said
you Robert I'm gonna put you in timeout
if you don't start acknowledging how
much you learn for me at that just camp
I am older than you young man I just
love bringing that oh I don't remember
anything that you've taught me so that
is not true I wash your mouth out was it
to polish cheer up oh my god um this it
change the subject you know I I deserve
to have a little bit of fun too right
yeah yeah hey I appreciate it but
alright you know what I really
appreciate how how grind it out this
game has become for Chris Rock look for
a combination that ends this one in fine
fashion rook takes a two and Knight
takes e4 check I'm calling it it doesn't
work but I'm calling it I was looking I
was like wait is that something who
takes a two overwhelms the Knight to
Knight takes e4 check but after King F 1
where's my follow up okay look for an e4
though I'm calling the tactic yeah and
Knight g4 it's coming so actually Knight
c5 is in chief all right away
yo no no 90 f6 was just perfect you're
right
takes rook g2 he'll give check on h4 and
then get back to tonight's coming in in
fact now Bishop h3 is a threat
ooh h3 it's coming I think our search
time like a perfect game this one no
this has been this has been vintage
Sascha wool in 96 96 he's gonna come in
to F for reinforcements Queenie one's me
Queen takes d6 Queenie one is mate yes I
just I just I'm like I'm like yah yah
yah from from the Sandlot just repeating
everything you say Sandlot okay okay c4
falls for d6 but in the end that's
probably not actually what go certain
once although okay let's give credit
where credit's do I feel like we should
have been announcing mates therefore
Grichuk and somehow Nepos still stands
yeah but I don't know how much longer
you stay is black only at one point well
I really thought black was up like three
pawns but it's only one so there are
still chances here for an IVA that's for
sure so okay and then an F for is super
strong no I mean he defended he defended
really well he still worse but I don't I
don't know if he's gonna lose this game
I mean he's definitely worse but it's
only one pond now all of a sudden why
he's getting more activity yeah yeah
this is getting much tougher so just
shook played the first part of this game
so well and now all of a sudden it looks
like nepo is over the clock situation as
well both sides under time pressure for
the first time in a few games and c5
pawn Oh
Knight back I wanted to say g5 g for
gonna create some chances against the
white king but krishna has other ideas
what so can I just push the pawn
sacrifice f3 and keep pushing and all I
think he's gonna do it whether he can do
it or not
yeah the pawn goes pretty far I guess
you're a knight c6 here you'd be happy
to give up a night for the a pawn if you
can then try to work it but maybe I'm
wrong maybe you end up getting mated cuz
two knights may not be able to meet a
king alone everyone but with a rook this
black King could be in trouble
well I just wanna play 96 but a 7-up
like rook e8 and just scoop off that
pony
so I'm stopping upon those tracks for
the moment but this is looking really
tough sometimes these these positions
with four nights on the Bourne Ingham
giving migraines like chess isn't
supposed to be played this way so many
nights here so many potential Forks wait
a second okay so brick just wants to
eliminate the complications now that
he's under ten seconds not a bad
practical decision unless he mates
himself with King of five king of three
okay I okay King of five wouldn't have
been made on King of three because it
rotates recheck but that would that
would have been Danny pulling a Danny
there commentators curse look dominguez
for I saw the highlight and he was not
happy about me me calling it was he he
was teasing about it but this is gonna
be should be a draw repetition killed
the cat and we have another peaceful
result huge practical victory for Annie
PO there though right I mean down to
games about to go down three and saves
them much worse position so yep and Wow
just I mean I don't even know what to
say because it looks so once I it looks
like me a brutal finish and Anita was a
tenacious defender there xeo animus says
Grichuk beautiful offensive beast upon
me ah she ferocious defender so there
you go oh I love this combo jimster 99
who are these player players where is
the car that's right up there with yakov
calling next I know there's always so
funny that was a great save though yeah
but it was alright so we have another
interesting position and an anti Moscow
and there tends to be so much theory in
these lines and you can go play b4 is
black and Italy pretty pawn to c3 but
then also white put a three to undermine
that pawn chain and it's just a lot to
consider here and they feel before
Bishop before wipe is Bishop e5 in
response because if you don't play
Bishop e5 you lose your pawn on e4 so
now after this should be five look h6
was played so how do I defend c3 Queen
c1 defense there it is defense
three an attacks chief I so giving up
the e4 pawn hoping to get g5 back it
looks like and what is going on here so
Black has up two pawns for the moment
two extra pawns and g5 is gonna fall
down B take C fall and win that pawn
back as well
the Bishop on b7 for now is not a very
good piece so I'm what lo he's not
expecting that but makes sense sometimes
you just start talking such wonderful
things that all I can do is listen I
mean I'm just trying to figure
everything out and so I'm sort of
talking to convince myself that I know
what's going on I feel like the more
that I say the more it seems that I know
what's going on but you know this
position is fairly obvious that white as
much right as I say that shocking
comment from much STV chat from a
username I'm not gonna pronounce says we
didn't hear Danny's voice for just a few
seconds so he missed it I think he's
being sarcastic why I miss your voice
honestly because it would have given me
a little bit of rest from speaking yeah
well you're doing great all right
who's better here again it's grish 'ok
and again nepo searching for the opening
that uh that's gonna help him this if
this pattern repeats and bullet I think
it's gonna be an issue that comes back
because I know I've made that comment
somewhat inch which said 2,700 needs to
fix his openings kind of maybe not
really believing but the day regardless
obviously these guys have high-level
prep everyone and and certainly his
openings are just fine not criticizing
criticizing the palm now she has a
player but from an approach in this
match in rapid blitz chess he has been
on the wrong foot more times than not
out of the first stage would you agree
Robert absolutely and right now his
position is really bad yeah well
material right do a quick count five
pounds each look to up special queen but
we've we've got a for Connie six and a
seven as we speak right even if I don't
take this pawn back look how ugly blacks
Pondexter every point is isolated Queen
takes six checks all by v1 a recording
would first I like that even better
because now you could take on a seven
and you're not worried about the bishop
being under fire okay Sony post-ops that
but
takes takes on c4 or do you take b7 and
play Brooke b1 check I guess you don't
get anything so no you miss so many good
moves rip d1 rook c1 bishop f3
definition about three would open up the
threat of rook takes B 7 and then Queen
takes c6 York that looks really strong
actually I was I wonder if I want to
play book c1 now your D to C 1 that is
to avoid the exchange yeah Queen c4 okay
how can you be upset about that move you
can take back with the Rooker a baby
even just the bishop just to keep the
Brook yeah yeah I like that it keeps the
bishop on free or under under the raise
the raise of the brook and here comes
the bishop back to f3 again yeah once
mister of three Evans there's always
four takes b7 check yep so black will
play queen g6 hoping the white blunders
the rook no he doesn't but bishop of
threes the same hope because if rook
takes f3 yep wishful thinking here so
Sasha can play so many different Queen
b3 so you can play Bishop up three max
lady yeah Queen b3 is a a good
prophylaxis to you just make sure you're
not gonna blunder he tactics and you
might even be threatening Bishop takes
h5 now Robert because the rook is
defended and that's a that's a third
pawn on the King side yep yeah Bishop
takes h5 is a simple threat here that's
so funny I wasn't even thinking about
that pawn it but you might be right just
scoop up that pawn bring it back to have
three and then go h4 h5 yourself yeah
okay well we didn't get it last game
that doesn't mean that the problems
aren't persisting for an upon me ah she
here 17 minutes left in the three
minutes so sometime to right the ship
which you don't want this to get into
that four or five game territory right
if Grisham wins this game Robert three
game lead is already a lot and job and
Nipah needs to solve the problems three
game lead is humongous and the way and
playing it's clearly it's very evident
that grace shook is the one with the
upper hand and so again I don't know the
bullet portion will be very interesting
yeah I feel like nepo should be the
favorite in bullet despite what our stat
predictions said I was kind of shocked
to see that I feel like nepo
okay he's not on Nakamura or I think
MBL's level or Magnus but I feel like
NEPA was one of the better bullet
players on the planet
whereas Grichuk is a very great blitz
player but we'll see how he holds his
own in bullet I you know we'll find out
right but I feel like Nepos should be
should have the edge in bullet well he's
doing more than holding his own right
now and he's a three game lead and weld
in it since you think that NEPA was a
favorite what lead or what deficit I
should say does me people have to have
in order to have a chance it's the
bullet you're asking me to put on the
prediction pants yep okay well you know
I think that I think that it has to stay
within two games
I feel like three games is too much you
know I'm making the prediction that I
think nepos the battle better player but
not by more than three games for sure
and three game is huge yeah three games
so I think I think he's already right
there right he's at that he's at the
ceiling of where you can really properly
stage a comeback and for those who
follow speeches championship history you
know there have been comebacks as big as
four games in the bullet portion before
I believe the biggest ever match deficit
that ever was a comeback was five games
but they weren't actually trailing by
four games in the bullet so so it is
possible but I would say not likely and
right now
NEPA for sure is all authorship right
now so wait what 92 right wins an
exchange wait 92 is on the board but
there's queen of five at the end maybe
know that I remove I've worked at g6 and
you're Queens under attack on f5 as well
yeah you're right he goes for it
rook d2 Bishop d2 Queen a5 rookie six
defends with tempo I mean didn't even
just blunder again this is like a full
tilt if that's the case well I think
he's 94 right the idea was played Knight
d2 to 4q Queen and rook and even with
the other ropes of d1 and well this is
just looking a little bit problematic
I'm gonna go email I'm gonna email in a
while Robert I went Evo knee pose on
tilt never go full emote whoa and Ewan
and Nathan F 314 did it oh my god that
was late for you there was like
milliseconds there's no way he could
have been comp
me they'd know I knew Nathan for you was
a great show hashtag Nathan field or
maybe that is Nathan fielder you wish
you watched Nathan for you know oh so
good sorry the kind of cringe-worthy
comedy that makes my wife leave the room
while I'm cracking up that's how good it
is
yeah sounds like Austin and commentary
together
I get the assist for that insult all
right Brooke f6 queen h5 what's funny is
nepo does have some outside shots at
compensation here bishop before a very
strong move to avoid Bishop e5 and said
compensation but even still right this
night on c5 is super strong and outpost
this is not that easy for black oh not
at all
because now especially after GT except
for which you had to play because rook
takes up 4 would have run into Quincy's
h6 so you have a weak pawn structure on
the Kings side you are not pawns
so essentially is a rook for a night but
the rooks don't have much activity in
the moment and that's in white currently
owns the only open file really on the
board which prevents black from using
the power of the rooks right okay AJ is
a very smart that that's the other open
file so you're right has a very strong
move someplace c6 here and then play
rook to g8 and just try to get your work
out so problem with rookie 5 is you want
to follow it with like Queen h4 Brooke
h5 right but you can't well the well the
Queen and so he just backs up but how's
he gonna beat Brooke g8 Queen of three
they just take on before well you don't
have to but I take them before in the
play Bishop f5 right straight off
bishops simplification yeah this looks
even with this happening I still don't
think it's so simple but I would have
liked you to avoided trading the bishops
I would I wish I could play a move like
Bishop up one here but you probably just
take c2 right yeah and or Brooke f2 g6
right like I'm sure he has it right so
now
okay nevermind I was gonna say what
words rook fg5 but then at four is
hanging time when the clock tells us
that we have probably at least one more
three minute game after this before the
bullet portion commences so well uh well
state keep our eye on the on the clock
here so cage seven okay you couldn't
want to look after g5 instead of qh7 the
idea is that if you hey Knight takes f4
this rook takes g2 tactically works but
I guess Queen takes a fart of is the
problem my comment about putting other
prediction pants has led to quite quite
the interesting direction of the
twitchchat not going to comment on that
chess TV she had a little more focused
on the chess and a rare occasion
actually I take that back chess TV chat
is not focused on chess all right well
white is still better I mean sorry black
is still better but white is is still
holding everybody protects each other
right
rook protects the pawn poem protects the
knight Knight protects the pawn it's
like Old MacDonald had a farm
yeah everything is well defended here
and from what I don't even see a move
for white king h2 maybe just sit tight
right sit tight
no but King G King H to rook F to g6 is
coming once again Knight takes and for
rook takes G to chat G spot comes back
you are the the haunting the yeah this
is an issue
you almost wanted I was gonna say can
you and you just dislodge the rooks now
looks like he's gonna try but f3 is
coming last three now is winning three
is is it just winning what's the idea I
thought absolutely G F 3 then Queen and
one check after a tricky one is defended
yeah there's no mate there would be a
mate everyone if the chief file opened
up on cheap one but okay he's gonna go
for it yeah rook e1 so he likes your
idea even if it's not winning apparently
this is this is scary I mean you are
you're you're staring down the barrel of
a four-game deficit and holding this
would be huge for both for White Queen
d4 is a very good move throws
rook F to g6 and there's no Queen up
five pins because the age for policy
wait guys take on at four yeah rook out
for a night at four Queen D one check
and a queen G one made oh the back door
the back door wait why did now Queen at
five is the only move you have to pay
advise pins the rooks and then maybe
just huh I guess that's also move one
funny line would be of black traded
everything on G to the to Brooks for the
Queen is maybe why can hold with again
everybody protecting each other right
that would be a quite a strange
situation now videos where Brooke g4
take on edge for and well now the issue
is both sides are gonna be under time
pressure so this high-quality affair
we've had of black trying to execute an
attack on the G file it's gonna become a
time scramble yep and now a triple on
the G file Queen g6 yep is the triple
and queens rated though that's fine
there's no mate oh there is no Queen
takes f5 in routine three kouchtown okay
Nepos shrugs it off he's gonna need to
brush it off here pretty soon this is
this is what to watch get out that was
rough and this is not how we expected
the the direction to be going Wow and
another grin felt and the Brooke b1 grin
so by saying you know you're not gonna
keep your pond b7 for too long if we do
somebody was b6 as a response and if
this is the the indeed the last game of
the three-minute which it could be
despite eight minutes on the clock
remember there's increment then then
this is you know based on my prediction
must-win territory for Nepal Miyoshi at
this point yeah I think we have we have
two more annually DMA Danny
we found nepo he's an ouch down oh man
nothing like using my own bad puns
against me to Shea and Ely the
yeah
chessy Beach at keeping things real on
point here with harsh of 7:07 saying
Hikaru is good yes did you not get the
sarcasm on that pretty factual you know
I'm trying to evaluate that statement
yeah that's that it was it was meant to
be met with silence and crickets so you
passed the test
f+ all right yeah this is this is much
more traditional grünfeld where we have
this two-on-one potential advantage for
black on the Queen side and and White's
gonna try to justify the center majority
before the endgame is reached but we saw
this type of structure a lot for those
of you who followed the match between
mvl and LDP you down with LD p LD p
linear Dominguez you don't know if I set
you down with LD P you're supposed to
say yeah you know me you down with LD P
see ya know how doesn't say something
never mind
I thought you were cool Robert but then
done anyway yeah I'm cool but I'll tell
you later
the imbalance okay yet that you held
back I appreciate that the imbalance in
the structure is an instructive one
though because you see this long-term
advantage for black trying to outweigh
White's initiative in the center and you
know the battle that takes place there
philosophically is interesting and this
h4 idea is really nice for white because
when you own the center and the position
is closed
you usually own more access points to
the side of the board like this so why
could maybe get away with h4 h5 and I'm
not saying he's mating black but it's uh
it's definitely an outside shot of some
complications for black to deal with on
the Kings side yeah now all of a sudden
the black is getting that activity you
need early residence in the ninth c7 was
awkward because it was just kind of
stopping you from taking over the C file
now okay 86 86 so then II for pawn how
do you keep that defendant you go neg g5
then I think black just says Knights c5
and you have a problem protecting this
v4 pawn 25 now it's well defended but is
it in danger being overextended that's
the real concern is that now the
two-on-one on the Queen side looks very
real yep so it may agree Queen f1 you
have
why did another movie yes somehow blacks
piece has infiltrated behind White's big
center this is about as rare a maneuver
that you see in a grunt field but here
comes the deep pond oh here comes the
h-file Dylan the D pawn versus Harry the
H file so am I gonna you know work
either h4 and just make me no it doesn't
work not gonna happen not gonna not
gonna get made it on the H file after g3
cleans you too but the D pawn is
overextended and I'm liking
Nepos chances to strike back here yeah I
honestly thought that grace Chuck's
position earlier was very nice but then
things have gone entirely but a lot of
miners came off the board so early that
it was never that ideal groan felt he
was having in the earlier kind of gambit
lines right yeah and now 96 and okay
wait wasn't f4 move there instead of
instead of 93 wasn't the rook on e5 stop
protecting him work on e4 uh Bueller
Bueller
I don't know they look pretty good well
I was just noting in the Brooks looked
kind of awesome a clue to what is
happening here by the way is there some
crazy line where he can take f2 rookie
five rookie three if you take e3 I have
94 and if you take up two I take my book
back whoa I know you just went you just
went killing Ariza on that whoa whoa to
the Batcave we go the analysis board
look at this line Knight up - rookie
five rookie three do you take here I
take here if you take here I have check
and then at the end I fork everybody the
emotes go wild no no but there's queen
bee - check I was like wow that looks
beautiful
Oh queen bee - check he's already dirty
girl alright well I had you at Keanu
Reeves you had me super confused
everywhere I mean as well as sure was
going on and yeah that was a good idea
though
give me credit for that consolation
prize 30 seconds for grig that's uh it's
less than a minute Captain Obvious
thank you
it was very interesting this you know
look can you take on d6 that a pawn that
can be captured risky right Knight takes
D 694 but okay rook h5 is gonna force
King's you one because you don't want
Queen entry with tempo still feels like
black could muster something against the
King here you got to put the Queen on g2
right otherwise Queen h3 is maybe it's
not gonna it's actually okay maybe I'm
wrong well queen g4 also comes to mind
Queens you - it looks fine goes to cheat
you anyway that the time pressure
combined with frets against the king
that's what nepo Nepos hoping for Queen
b5 rook Des Moines oh I missed it it
guards the f1 square holy bleep oh man
but it's not over yet but that was super
nice right there Queen B 1 takes a - wow
that was that was a nice game and in
time to get one more three-minute one in
looks like Nebo very aware of the total
match clock as clock is asking us on our
zoom call here but I believe there is
one more yes that's like two and a half
almost a half minutes left so one last
game I love the nose hey guys guys guys
one more you know one more
they're both leaving we're gonna have to
abort the game this is hilarious both
players decided that it was time for a
break you know what since they agreed
it's a break maybe we should just take a
break at this point the total match
clock is gonna come down to both sides
losing and I know it's it's rare that I
have to step in and pull an audible but
I don't know what to do when both sides
leave and this is leading to a pretty
funny moment alright here's what we're
gonna do because both sides agreed Pete
go ahead and abort the game I know
you're listening I'm making the
executive decision that this game will
not count we will be moving to bullet in
just a moment but since I have
everyone's attention for some pretty
funny stuff I want to remind you that
tomorrow is not
more speeches championship but the arena
kings final is gonna take place those
are the pairings for those of you who
have not followed the biggest thing in
streaming chess
since the mouse was invented narrow disk
II Hess hammer my partner right here
Eric Hanson of the chess bras so $15,000
in prizes for season one tomorrow's
starting at noon is the championship of
the streamer's championship we're gonna
take about a 92nd break go ahead and
enjoy some beautiful waiting music Robin
and I will be right back we're back
we're back we're back I still can't get
over that people heard me typing away a
mile a minute
I have heard you're pretty high wpm I'm
not gonna lie I'm proud of him the hit
the keyboard like it owes me money
anyway Robert our players are also back
the executive decision seems to have
been understood by both of them that we
are now that we are now moving on to
bullet which pretty fun $126 from you
the fans directly into their pockets we
appreciate it the bullet portion let him
know if you got any more loving yeah but
this has been super exciting honestly a
big win for an upon me ah she he was
down by four back in the three game mark
leaves him within striking distance
looks like the games have begun and and
we have liftoff the bullet segment
begins yeah and actually the more I've
seen restrict play the more I've been
liking his chances in bullet because he
seems to have a very good control over
his opening and game after game he's
gotten pretty decent positions out of
the opening with the white pieces
especially with black he's also had some
good showings but the Scotch is a very
dangerous opening to Faison bullet
because there's a lot of weird theory
sometimes you win upon his black but
you're still worse here for example you
you know the 95 was under attack you'd
have retreat it and both these players
should know the theory here but it's
quite complex yeah and a good try in
bullet I think to start mixing it up
obviously
a little bit biased to the Scotch you
know depose one of the top players I
follow who plays my opening and I think
that if he had any preparation before
the match not busting up the Scotch
until the fastest segment maybe that was
part of his idea we should ask him
afterward yep
and right now 94 was played he had a sit
for a think and I guess f5 follows and
then 94 is well defended so well okay
but like from a practical point of view
white clearly has a lot of pressure it's
almost like playing the Kings gambit
where you may be down upon for a long
time but what in reality you're getting
so much pressure on your opponent so
here
okay the Queen trade is a very smart
decision by grace shook you can't just
get your King into trouble so he's gonna
cast a long and maybe he's just better
although I hate the bish 1a 6ob piece
and you can't get out anytime soon so I
guess you like at the same time our
Bishop d4 fall by c5 might be the way to
go
that's a best looking like the option
here Bishop d4 rookie one place c5 there
it is and who is better or is it just
equal so black is taking over the e-file
which leads me to believe that black is
better because the double pawns here are
actually quite good and the fact the
pond c5 defends his Bishop on before so
Bishop takes f3 + gfk rookie - and if
rip d2 you played rook e1 check kimchi
soup rook to you 1 check me pick up the
fisherman g5
so unfortunately me postseason flicks a3
you know it's there's work eights you
know this is really nice for black now
the king and just are running it do it
a4 King b-17 b6 q a5 king before is
certainly an option here I hate when I
promote my own opening and it backfires
interesting king c6 I mean it does make
sense but I thought is even rook c3 here
I don't make probably just sit tight
though and it ends peacefully so bit of
a surprise for me but concern the match
score it makes sense
I love the hope that everyone's paying
attention I made a yeah I made a
broadcasting production boo boo for
about a split second and it's been
pretty funny noticed by both shots so
good job guys
that's what happens when you got a
one-man band here alright I'm playing
guitar drums singing vocals and my foot
on that weird keyboard thing that makes
everything sound longer all right lay
off me we see a French Danny Oh
the first French it rears its ugly head
just in time to get criticized this is
oh no why French why so that Bishop a
six it wasn't hanging as Queen a five
check would have picked a bishop back up
on a six and now actually it doesn't
look so bad for it's not the worst
French we've ever seen I agree yeah I'm
so anti French defense Knight h5 though
this just I can't look at this position
and not get excited about mating
positions well nope not gonna not go
Stoops here log not gonna stupid though
all right well you had your opportunity
right I withheld my comment all right
well okay black is still holding on
pretty well the good thing with the
French and bullet is you have very
compact structures you don't have to
worry about hanging pawns at all the
time the bad news is at least in
classical chess you lack space and it's
easy for whites of play and I see Ana
chess saying what did you say about the
French of course yeah that's right easy
here it comes all right Queen h5 is is
happening probably pushing the Jeep on
this next main issue is the g7 pawn is
stuck without h6 falling so rook b3 a
nice a nice potential piece to join the
attack along the third-ranked so
this is just stuck for black very tough
here comes the attack that happens in
every French structure as black just
sits there and hopes for a blunder yeah
now it's a g5 and here comes clean break
do it and the night on h7 is looking
great King eh to get your King out there
it is get became up the G file and what
can black do here Oh
like I said hope for a blunder oh man
you know what would have been so sweet
if there was some sort of smothered on
g6 but instead of asking my partner for
a night in bug house I'll just play g6
and win a piece yep nepo frustrated he
shakes shakes his head and and moves on
but a four-game deficit while has been
overcome he's putting himself in that
kind of territory where it's just
because players at this level even
though we talk about the format Robert
where they are sometimes likely to lose
a few games in a row because you lose
one the emotions get you you don't have
time for a break like you want to turn
them in but when Europe when you're down
four games the chances of them losing
four games you know before they sort of
gather themselves mentally emotionally
it's just not very high so that's why we
call it kind of an irreversible deficit
despite the fact that we'll probably see
another ten bullet games this is just
it's getting too far out of reach for
Nebo
yeah and gritch tricks also just playing
better so not only is it a big lead he's
the one play it's not like he's getting
lucky he's just playing well so between
g6 here tre the Queen's and we're gonna
see a better end game for black and the
bishop will come to f5 you can play you
move your bishop away from b4 and play
c5 the Bishop e7 for example okay
somehow something weird is happening
Robert because we now see that Gehrig
Meier has joined us in the chat but I'm
not really sure how that's possible
given that he's also standing right next
to me you are a very foolish man a a man
walked in silenced his weapon and took
care of things on the arena Kings but
then missed the championship despite all
the hard work to have a fat head ready
for the arena kings championship Gehrig
Meier travelling unfortunately but meet
meet George Gruber I don't think he
watched the show yesterday so I had to
show him the latest fat head to join
magnetic ro and
oh just hanging out in the office it's a
party here yeah that's amazing so Hans
Meyer Hans Meyer I like that that's
awesome
Hans Meyer George Gruber which one's
better well let will let bollec York
choose in the chair you like the
alliteration but Hans Meyer sounds
pretty pretty good me all right what's
going on this end game so c5 okay so
that's a past deep on but it's not going
very far
yeah it feels like NEPA should have a
chance 92 94 whoa b4 what's the idea
yeah too soon rook takes a for you he's
hoping for mating Nets rook beat rook
takes rook b8 no but there's nothing to
it it was too soon it's all happening so
fast summer lovin George York confirms
that George Gruber is just fine okay
well you know what yoga also said he was
playing a 45 yeah today so he's avoiding
that French nope the French doesn't love
me anymore that's that's real sad for
Anna Anna Anna's heart breaks one of the
the last men standing where have all the
good men gone right Anna you know you
need a hero
the was that a Paula Cole song like
where have all the Cowboy's gone where
of all the Frenchmen gone any hooters
well okay seriously right now for games
focus on the chest we've got about what
do we got here we've got about 20
minutes left for nepo to stage a
comeback so it starts now I don't know
if it's gonna start when he's isn't he
down upon and it's gonna be a hard pause
to regain because it's well protecting
the e5 square so about that comeback hmm
Yahtzee really not seeing it happen
right now no I agree and there just
hasn't been enough enough diversity too
and then trying to find new ways to to
beat Erick so who a 95 coming for the f7
square yeah
okay what time to grab the D file unless
Bishop c5 is something no nothing h4 h5
oh man can you imagine 9 h8 bishop h7
mate and the crowd goes wild and the
problem is you also can't go h6 because
Knight takes f7 happened the problem is
it's actually very hard to stop the
threat of h5 9 h8 and Bishop h7 mate
now here's thanks f7 whoa oooh
Intermezzo they takes d9 takes d8 Knight
takes F 566 things are hanging and I
take C 6 with temple on the rook I like
it bishop okay she backs up at 9 and h4
has many squares to go to yeah I mean
that the there may even be just the
threat of rook F 4 okay g5 saves it but
III if you wanted I just play g3 and
force the trade on a5 yeah he likes it
so what's white out two pawns now yes
you pawns double Brooks on the F file no
try to simplify and undal your own pawns
when you have four games in the match
you know you don't you just really need
not to lose you mean he should play for
winnings up to pawns but I think the big
issue for nepo is you're almost in the
territory where you should resign this
game right I mean there's a very good
chance that you defend this game for
another minute and a half two minutes on
the total game clock and lose anyway yep
right and that's and that's a serious
problem I mean here King of 3G for these
moves just sort of play themselves Danny
dog Oh dug a wolf wolf isn't hurting my
feelings in the chat I'm sorry he wants
to mute me and not you he's been kind of
mean all day so I'm not sure what to say
alright these six here comes b5 we're
gonna try and put the rook on d5
everything on the light squares makes
this dark squared Bishop a dull boy the
I know you get that reference I sorry I
was looking at the board and I was
saying to use a horror movie buff you
are but wait what did you say I didn't
hear it I said pawns I said every piece
on white squares makes the dark square
Bishop a dull boy
you're good you're good one Danny
alright well another another victory for
Grichuk five games surprising as
surprising as it is the some maybe not
to others heading in to this heading
into this portion we had the lead that
you see on the board there the
predictions gave gave the nod to sasha
alexander grishnak by about a game in
the bullet in a game in the five minute
but this thing was deadlocked after five
minutes it was really the three-minute
portion that saw Agora kind of flex his
muscles and so seven a half ten and a
half heading in a bullet is now a five
game lead yep
and good shirts still doing well with
both colors and here with black okay so
what's going on take on note b8 maybe do
I take on I can't take on d6 I guess a
rook b8 take Danny I feel bad now
because you get did a great shining
reference and I just didn't give you the
attention you deserve it's alright it's
alright I come back and I was in my head
I was trying to come up with some sort
of dinner a bra we see this line where
did we see this line and what and what
SCC was it it was Dominguez it was
Dominguez Perez bling black against
Meyer a few times in this cattle and you
remember look familiar but I'm not
positive so I really couldn't say
and isn't black just like totally and
absolutely fine here yeah I mean here
black is more than good and I'm sure
would probably accept a draw offer if
giving it even though from a match
strategy perspective although you
remember of all the top players we
talked to Griffith is the one who most
openly said you know that he really
thought out the match time control
strategy last year and was trying to get
things into the bullet you remember that
yeah
it's interesting they here to agree to
withdraw their like he's you were just
mentioning he should why again I think I
think from this perspective I think he
knows that he's really in the driver
seat here of five games with 15 minutes
15 minutes left but but I was surprised
by - okay but here he's just I mean this
is just bad chest for black these
positions are just they're just worse
it's just funny because we you know it
turned into a French essentially with a
[__] run b7 it's like a worse version
of the French and I admit I play this
kind of stuff you know I'm just like
common blitz but no this is literally a
French with the worst possible setup for
black it's horrible age for you take
back with the pawn now you have no real
tension to worry about the Queen can
inch worm her way over here to g4 Queen
III queen of 44 seriously not a bad plan
along with g4 g5 okay he plays Bishop
here he's probably gonna flip a battery
and maybe go to h6 with a sack and and
by the way Robert how does black stop
Queen d2 and Bishop takes h6 like
without playing a move like f5 and
completely destroying the structure yes
there's no way to stop it that's how bad
this close position is that you can't
even deal with this threat on h6
you can play aged five years oh there
you go well it's the only way to do it
you have to change the structure and
willingly take on this backward Pesce
this Bishop g5 work here Bishop c5 oh
that would have been nasty just say the
h1 and now Queen g3 you can flip over
although I don't want to hang him okay
but he agrees that it's just fine what
happens on 94 I saw Queen g3 first and
then saw 94 and said don't do it but
then he went for it
commentators curse he read Danny's mind
and now he regrets it he should have won
Bishop g5 yeah he should okay so hey
Chad before you yell at me I caught
myself on Queen G 3 before blundering
the pawn but Grichuk didn't so now all
of a sudden the French survives still to
live another day it French is up a pawn
and still structurally probably slightly
worse yeah
okay D for my trying to figure out
what's going on so maybe go with the C
file here he plays g5 but at some point
you might just flip to the C file and
use that as the new means to get to the
black King no no he doesn't want any
plays rookie to obviously the guard than
me gonna go after the e pawn queen e5
he's in passive defense I thought using
a rook c4 at some point and get active
but now yeah now white can play rook e5
put the clean back on e3 that's what
he's doing
always important to lead with a rook in
a queen and double rook battery if you
can look at if it was a good move you
take any 696 pushing me six rookie six
look up one check maybe yeah trades yeah
try it again
she's six interesting move great move
great move
GG one no perpetual chest yeah and you
have this constant idea of a mating net
look for Queen reading what could be
three check was winning yeah Oh Queen b3
check everyone King H a queen back to h3
Yeltsin a queen yep
no the Queen was on c8 yeah but there's
a queen Trey and that's a winning pawn
ah okay so yes it was winning just not
buy mate now it's a draw yeah this
position every one Queen to b3 ah ah too
late to show it we're already moving on
but okay we'll give him a pass they
haven't made many slips of a1 move one
move missed win although we do have to
remind him about rook she won oh yeah oh
yeah I don't even know how to how to how
to jog his memory of the game know how
to describe it but 6000 of you with us
here thank you for tuning in reminder
right after this will be the title
Tuesday coming up with Grandmaster
amount Hamilton hosting commentary you
don't have to go anywhere right here at
twitch.tv class chess and chess calm TV
in fact if you go anywhere I will find
you
oh so it's a 5 game lead right yep with
12 so essentially it's already
pretty much it's getting there yeah I
mean there you know and what's
interesting is in this bullet portion
there it wasn't like it was over and he
missed a couple chances to stage a
comeback I can't think of a game where
we're you know the result happened that
wasn't meant to happen at this point
Grichuk is in control yeah Chris tricks
playing very accurately and very well
and Nebo try and play quickly in this
game but something black is better
here's look it up on c4 you've you've
gained space you can play for a 5 at any
moment
we put f6 and then e 5 well that's a
schtick so what's the Queen's to come
off but no yeah you couldn't went C 3
for black but there's no reason to rush
that move you can just leave this pawn
c4 forever at some white would love to
get Eve for if you're playing this
structure and undermined the protection
the C pawn but blacks pieces are just
ideally placed Oh a night to see five
the pin I love that move tray Queen
wasn't a queen before pinning back Queen
before pinning back a pin for a pin as a
bjorg Gruber would say thank you so now
what's going on here c4 is a target
officially but taking it might be
poisoned here comes the doubled look
what's going on can he get away with
that
no no he just lost a piece you ever
retreat your queen back oh that's a free
piece right now and you have to move
your queen wait yeah this is winning
it's just winning for Chris chick yeah
just
I thought you could ever treat your
queen back and use the penalty this is
winning anyway but still just Nebo just
really really on a bit of a tilt here
it's perfection by can't guard anything
well and knee bow shakes his head super
accurate played by Grichuk a very
frustrated depandi Yoshi I love that
comment
maybe Danny Quan chinks this match into
a playoff I'll try hard that would be
awesome at this point it's all over
Karishma Quinn's you know sugar is
really dominating I will I will go out
on the limb to drink to jinx it so fo I
used to play this is black it's kind of
suspicious but also you know can be
interesting if you're prone doesn't know
what they're doing well this looks quite
nice for white almost full bullet full
bullet openings here but like it's full
bullet but now that blacks thinking here
so I mean full bullet but good for white
I agree yeah usually your castle before
doing this from black that way you don't
trade off the works on me hey chief I
use e6 maybe yeah no you just take on
that five as well there he does it
Bishop g5 yep so hard right now Grichuk
so hot right now he really is just
amazing Castle queenside and then what
is
something g4 g3 get that Bishop on the
long diagonal yeah I like it
g3 Bishop g2 okay okay he wants to
support the pony does he plan for beat
for feels a super double edged I liked
your plan better the d4 square yeah
feels a feels a little flimsy here I I
wondered if there was a move like Queen
g7 there by black get to get the battery
going but okay nothing yet this is
probably five if you put the other night
on c6 there's a nice c5 yeah yeah c5 as
well well why can't my seat you up
there's c5 a6 is hanging d6 is under
attack and you'd love to play queen of
seven but why don't just trade in
transition to the winning ending so yep
a full tilt
Nepos gone full tilt and you're designed
Wow well frustrated in the palm neon she
obviously not gonna be as good of a year
for him this year as he had in the
speeches championship last year for
those who remember he he lost a car
Aachen but started off very well so a
tough a tough pairing I can tell you
that both these guys were you know a
little bit questioning when they first
saw the pairing not knowing that it had
nothing to do with any choice by the
organizers but totally chest coms
ratings which was the public publicly
announced form of qualification and in
the way we were seating it so but I took
it from both players as neither one of
them really wanted to play each other in
the first round
nope and I don't think either one one to
see cardiac in as their next round upon
either yeah which is which is true
somehow the Russian side of the bracket
is very stacked but but that's it yep
and well for Brooke we'll see if he's up
for the task of playing cardiac and he
plays like he did today I think he is a
very good chance for cardiac and of
course well he's to get past Duda like
let's not put the cart ahead of the
horse but that's actually not true
subscriber and grin culture asks if the
players can see each other and a few
people said no that's actually not true
they can see each other we are in a
group call
all which is a service that chess comm
subscribes to much more stable when
compared to Skype or other types of
group video calls so I all that they can
see each other and chat with each other
directly in a private group that we have
going and so that's actually not true
players can't see each other
yep me Robert
and the players sitting in a tree
streaming chess calm Danny I was gonna
ask you about those triple G pawns right
now pass there are not the prettiest
ones with ephors falling next I mean
Danny didn't Nipigon Full Tilt last year
against carjacking in the end he did
yeah well it was so interesting because
the style there was like you know
karaoke just made it completely you know
a very technical very strangling
positional style of chess and I think
nepo just got frustrated by the end here
there was you know a lot of chances from
Nebo all day but just tactically seem to
be a small step behind Grichuk and
honestly some of those times cannibals
where grishnack held on in one games
they shouldn't have won I think they
were kind of back breakers for for Nico
right there was that endgame that he
blew with the night getting trapped
there was the game where he was what was
the game where he was just winning in
the in the in the Dutch right but then
Grisha came back and won down the
exchange yeah and there was the any loss
of time that game and there was also the
game but was having this one speaking of
coming back didn't didn't like just lose
a piece but there's another game that I
was thinking about now I forgot because
I saw a problem so this one whites have
a piece I am 25 seconds left but with
just you know over five minutes
remaining in this match Berger shocked
you might as well play to checkmate also
doesn't actually pair that easy to win
with the GG pawns defending the king so
for now we just be maneuvering back and
forth with the Queen's avoiding Queen
traits for black trying to Queen trade
or a white
it's a Bishop c4 there it is Queen H a
check we takes g7 and all right we don't
have a shutout was that the first win
for no no the second win I guess for a
neat bow and bullet so yeah it's been
very one-sided though in this segment
and you know for those of you seeing the
score saying that okay Grix up by six
games well if this were even going into
the bullet I think the bullet score
would be a little bit different
young depressors been on me post is a
very beginning he's been feeling it and
okay what's going on here so it's a
budapest budapest by george ezra figure
how it's clean b5 here comes 95
grishnack is uh okay don't make yourself
funny too but i'd love to get away with
95 if i could know might be three is
played Bishop d2 d3 is just sent by the
e3 I guess so it doesn't actually do
anything so White's up a pawn right yeah
I mean it was a it was a budapest gambit
so not ideal by the way the queen
couldn't take there everyone rookie one
would have trapped the lady now a three
okay usually you play a three and then
try to Rima new ver to get b4 on the
Queen side and the and the budapest for
white but should still be good enough
for a slight edge for the rest of the
game with only three minutes left
possible we only have one more game
after this yep and so now night no
hanging g3 nevermind g4 is good like I
seen that me for my bishop runs you to
my first inclination is a place with 94
but I was hanging my g3 bonus
Timothy Connelly trying to get the
Katherine obvious award if they were
even Grichuk would not be winning by as
much their even he'd be winning by zero
I can also be Captain Obvious right in
return so that night I need to is
trapped okay it was an album counter
game but you're right not a Budapest but
the structure was a direct transposition
okay for those calling me out yep dog
word ever woof woof just bullying us all
day yep ah real positive cat that guy
well I think there you try to get on his
nerves becau hey you're supposed to let
the subtle insults it so that we don't
have to point every one of them out yeah
but I haven't thought about cat dog in
like 12 Yemen you haven't thought about
cats and dogs living together okay in
all seriousness though fans in the chat
if you do have any questions for the
players now's your chance we have about
two minutes left in the total game clock
before we're joined by the russian super
GM duo
these guys are pretty good friends and
teammates so hopefully we get some fun
conversation and I have a couple
questions lined up that me the specific
chess questions but Robert what do you
think what do you think some questions
ask them well I mean I got to ask Sasha
you know he prepared specifically in
against the Grune fell in this match
because seemed like he was getting very
good positions I don't know for free on
it just seems like whenever he felt
frustrated with his time advantages in
the five-minute portion but not being
able to score the victories right yeah I
don't know it's yeah if that lingered
with him there I agree and I'm curious
why nepo didn't try for the Scotch more
I guess that's my bias question but
alright so the time is ticking away
everyone less than a minute now on the
total game clock we have not informed
the players yet that this is officially
their last game but we will be doing so
as soon as we know it is their last game
yep oh that's someone just said did
Chris Chuck practice bullying and bliss
so that that might be a good question
checking the switches ask Sasha how life
is treating him let's see yeah I'm
trying to read all these questions now
but I'm in this game right now black is
up a pond and unites h4 is coming at
some moments soon ladies come off
although now the a pond has some outside
chances maybe Nebo ends this thing on a
on a kind of wins in a row
almost that was a good transition for
white for sure that was somewhere along
the line we got another $1 donation to
the prize fund so we do thank everybody
for their support both in your
viewership your subscriptions everything
you do for chess these events happen for
and because of you guys so thank you all
right now White has a problem you'd like
to play Bishop a5 to defend the pawn but
that would block the rook okay but he
gives check first now Bishop a5 and rook
a 7 as a threat and maybe nepo ends it
on another win here no d8 oh ok should
we call it I thought now you deal with
you know I don't know I think the C pawn
is going to be used a distraction and
once that happens oh we can't protect it
can't you this trip to see threes a nice
smooth oh I was gonna say bring the King
to eat you first and then play a3 create
a mating net but he didn't weigh the
king is mated right is he made it
rook d5 and Bishop d2 yeah there was a
potential g4 check no horse she won rook
d5 before doing this I think AHA that
would have been sweet rook d5 would have
trapped the King on her for with mating
nets I think you're right Robert I think
that was winning
you got meeting at next in my head so I
was like well two kings on f4 you put
your hand right must be must be mates on
the brain isn't that a Rihanna song must
be mates on the brain I never heard that
one you've never heard of Rihanna no I
know you're the worst I deserved it I
honestly deserved it but rookies oh gosh
okay but he does get the win and he does
finish the day on a very very high note
and they finished the day by playing an
unnecessary
game free chess everyone free chess
everyone they don't well let them know a
little bit more
there's bjh gifted subs to the one and
only Peters fiddler the greatest chess
commentator on the planet we salute you
fiddler is awesome fiddler is awesome
you know he's not gonna be upset by the
way Yann played his Grunfeld today I
mean sorry not gonna be happy yeah he is
definitely gonna be gonna be upset yeah
if you missed it if you missed it peer
not the best Grunfeld for black so here
another Owen defense wait what is this
99 b3 is it that a thing with 9b3 it's a
thing it's a thing for Russian
schoolboys when they're being rebellious
blocking their bee pollen well you have
to protect the d4 pawns I guess there
was a sadness s 'ti at this point okay
the C file is usually a problem
officially everyone this game will not
be counting toward the score it is free
chess for you so you're welcome but
we've got some interesting questions for
these two players so please don't go
anywhere and as we already said right
after this the title Tuesday will be
starting at the regularly scheduled time
1 p.m. Pacific yep and in this game
we're entering an end game because this
is not officially part of the match I'm
wondering if I actually to commentate
because well it's sort of not really in
my job description to comments in a
games outside of the match because you
don't just commentate on chess all the
time because you love it yeah just sit
here you know soundly no that's what
that's actually not true he does just
sit there by himself commentating on a
couch there's one time Danny that was
one time you caught me doing that mob
one time I don't want you to tell people
about it so I'm pointing out my shiny
shiny red cheeks here I've got a cold
still but I'm fighting it off so anyway
here we go what do we got King back we
got nothing here Oh II fives falling we
got something
ooh g5 is falling you're right that's a
problem
at some point you're gonna play for biz
number 94 check I guess that means
before whatever black tea there's a for
this looks should be winning the black
you have to pawn the rook on d4 not in
the best shape has to go g3 Nebo
continuing to the fork emote a great way
to end the show no guys guys guys here
we go here we go game has been a forced
abort now that was awesome you guys are
awesome and we now have we now have both
the players with us you guys you guys
weren't done playing jest did you know
that that that last game you played was
also an overtime that the match was
already over you suspected it okay
oh well basically the mission was over
like half an hour ago so change it to
what well it was extra chess for the
fans so we do appreciate that and brito
obviously on the day didn't go as well
as you would have hoped for
where do you feel that the match started
to get away from you there in the
three-minute portion Grishka got on kind
of a run and what was the what were the
difficulties for you there yeah well
clearly I should feel one like
five-minute session like bus free up was
to clean because I mean okay this is
just three completement conclude
tradition oh yeah okay when you're
losing time position and you know likely
ever made by force in the next game we
are not winning just you know the first
category and game rights change all the
polls and promote people and you know it
was I believe three or four games like
this or I lose a lot of points and it
was very you know I was really I was
really mad at some point about least and
that's why I couldn't control my
emotions too well in the free cross one
section and at some point I started
jumping yeah okay
never goes sake when you tunes phenol
even in every game in the same reason
well I of course I mean now like I
couldn't tell you like this so I almost
like - for - for the station of three
plus one energy then I mean okie sachets
something betting by ballot invalid so
yeah they're looking but I mean more or
less logical outcome well you you hit
the nail on the head we were we were
prepared to ask you if you felt that
maybe those two tough losses from the
five-minute portion the the Dutch game
obviously where you were winning is
black and then yeah okay I couldn't
expect these to us you know especially
it was my time you know yeah obviously
players of your level and and those who
you play in both the extreme of elite
over the board chess tournaments and
then hours of online blitz at times when
you guys are having fun and can you talk
a little bit about the difficulty of
this format when you're playing very
serious online blitz unlike just a few
hours of fun and the difficulty to kind
of adjust yourself when you start to get
on tilt right emotionally you don't have
time to take a break and there's no rest
day like there would be in a tournament
and is that just something that it's
just really hard to do to stop yourself
from thinking about previous losses
no no that's in great format I do see
suggestions one is maybe introduce an
option of resigning they might because I
know by myself when you are losing
heavily okay you don't want to continue
like I had one of my matches with
Michaels and also if you are winning
okay for me there is no pleasure to
continue when I am plus six or plus
seven like today I don't know I mean
some guys specialize like Chicago they
get a lot of pleasure whatever it was 20
I mean but for me there is no no I don't
enjoy it I just want to win the match I
don't care it's plus ten plus one so I
mean I think it will be good for both
players
when
but there is big gap and there is no
chance to tie so much well maybe maybe
because because I for me it's all the
rage I don't like creeps time I get half
a minute down after the break I don't
know maybe make a break one minute more
I don't think it will ruin observers
experience but what players will be my
spectrum because for me when I smoke
then I don't have a time to go to the
restroom I mean I'd say I absolutely
love your feedback this is awesome I
appreciate it
and the well young what do you think I
you know we have had five game deficits
overcome before Sasha
so OH yawn what do you think I have
nothing to it well yeah I was actually
asking you what you thought about about
the difficulty to kind of overcome like
you said the previous losses but we
won't go back to that point
Sasha we actually did some specific
questions for you you you seem to be
very well prepared at least to start the
five minute portion against the grünfeld
you had this variation obviously the
pawn sacrifice that leads to the the
center grip and the King side attack as
compensation was this something you
prepared specifically for this match or
just something you prepared before and
yan went into it okay I prepared before
but I polished it for this match I mean
I actually was sure it will go like this
Broomfield okay at the end we'll stop
playing do you think he will switch to
that okay Wow okay and when he will be
again disappointed by touch and at some
point please I'll be in contact and it
will show up which which it needs so for
me it was not surprised
okay bye only for me the problem at the
beginning was that I could not hold
black color I mean I just tried berlin's
and medals and Petroff and everywhere I
was just suffering good way yeah and
then only in three minute person
instructed to go okay from this place
Yan did you have time to prepare
openings and did you know that Sasha
already knew you were going to play the
unfold and then switch to the Dutch or
was that a surprise to you no well okay
clearly or anything for this measure
okay I just was playing some normal
openings and we have Chris kudos to
Sasha keeps preparing for the bridge
I mean released it must be so fun and
yesterday it was so pleasant to face
this de fight in Greenfield because I'm
in a key mean blitz it's very you know
he sponsor prophetic presence you free
is more or less easy quiet to you know
to play and then okay I don't think I
was very successful English was
basically for some another type of
positions and well okay but in general
the you know this course shows the
confession however always played just
much better and okay he deservedly one
indicated only thing I can do is to
congratulate thank you the the next
round then Sasha for you will will
indeed be against the winner of Sergei
Kuryakin and young Christoph Duda I
think your countrymen there Sergei is
clearly the heavy favorite so tell us a
little bit about what you'll need to do
to have a chance to to defeat Sergei
Kuryakin in the next round I know but
what he will have to do to favorite
chance do you think yeah I didn't mean
it like that what I meant was what how
do you think that match going how do you
think you match up with Miss Sergei no I
think now okay Martinus is number one in
blitz and Kuryakin and Nakamura they're
like sequencer I mean just judging by
the results because you know resolve
don't like I mean you can say races guys
always getting lucky and so on but when
you take a lot of tournaments and these
guys and clearly they show the best
result and so yes which is one of the
toughest where support but for me I
don't know I I just want to play against
the strongest yeah lady Magnus is not
playing so it's already good are already
good for you as we pointed out to this
match the only player to beat you so far
in the speech s Championship has been
Magnus yeah twice
all right well Robert any other
questions before we let our players go
we really appreciate you guys hanging
out a lot of the fans are still here
they love you I don't know I'm pretty
speechless that was a really exciting
match early on and Sasha I guess for you
did you feel like at a certain point
that the openings were going your way
and even though the score was going
pretty even throughout the five minute
portion do you feel then that things
will start turning your way or were you
worried about some of your time trouble
no but I think we were just both
questioned with white I mean I mean at
least by by the character of games
because even this Petrov's they were
okay for me objectively for sure but
it's quite unpleasant to play with black
and young is very very good in such
positions with small age but no risk is
extremely good and yeah a bit white of
course I was getting very promising
future well congratulations to you
obviously an NT on this is this was a
very exciting close match I think closer
than the final score reflected there but
appreciate you both we we had a great
time
obviously Sasha you move on and into the
next round and we will we will see you
probably within within a couple months
for that match and thank you both have a
great night there have a great night
Thanks yeah all right I'll see you guys
okay and there you have it Robert as we
said Grichuk moves on here you can see
him now highlighted in the bracket
moving on into the the next round it was
pretty funny when I asked him what he
would have to do to have a chance
against Sergei you see his response
these guys are competitors he didn't
like the way I phrased that question
yeah I mean I always loved Sasha's
interviews and his responses very
quick-witted but yeah I mean he's been
one of the best competitors throughout
this history chess championship he's
only lost to Magnus and well if he plays
like he did today I don't even know if I
consider him and that big of an underdog
playing as someone likes to be a Kraken
despite the fact that Kraken
is a beast in the bliss format as
Krishna himself said yeah and cariocans
been playing the super high quality
blitz recently those who followed the
the summer series of blitz and rapid
events you know that Akari Aachen did
win already one of the blitz legs of the
grand chest or right and is also a
former world blitz champion not not this
last round but the year before in Qatar
so it'll be a battle of two Russian
former world champions of course we're
counting out the young kid maybe future
World Championship count challenger not
how not sure how many people had Duta
pulling the 14 seed upset over number
three car yakin but who knows right it
should be fun to see it to see a new
face absolutely
Robert it's always great to see your
face and thank you for thank you for
being here remind everybody that right
after this Aman Hamilton will be live
with the title Tuesday so please don't
go anywhere and one last shout out to
the fact that tomorrow is the
championship the last event of the first
season of the streamers the streamers
championship and we will have amazing
matchups all day including all the names
you see on the board right there you got
tang and Lenderman they were disky
you've got hess taking on Trent how do
you figure how do you fare against
against Lawrence Trent tomorrow I don't
know I'd even realized I was playing him
until you kept people get bring it up
and I saw Lawrence in the chat making
some comments so yeah I'm looking
forward to it hopefully I learn a little
bit from Sasha Gray shook today and
young Anupam mushy and we'll see how it
goes but I'm hoping to take him down of
course all right well good luck I will
be providing commentary tomorrow while
you're playing my friend congratulations
again to mr. grishnack who moves on and
thank you to all of you who were here
the prize fund donated by all of you
today and we will see you in the next
speech Chess Championship match until
then
you